okay
good morning welcome to the meeting of
Labor planning committee I will now ask
the government's officer to read out the
domestic arrangements and the fire
regulations
thank you
[Music]
persons in the chamber and in the social
areas please ensure that you wear a mask
unless you are speaking or if you're
unable to do so and that you use the
hand sanitizer and wipes provided
please maintain social distance at all
times during the meeting and during any
breaks please ensure that microphones
are muted when you are not speaking and
that you do not interrupt other speakers
members are reminded that they should
not have alternative communication lines
open and that if you are contacted by a
third party during an application you
should bring this to the legal advisor's
attention
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently enter at the
meeting you may be asked to leave
Additionally you will be invited to
speak and ask questions by the chair of
the meeting and we'll be using the
e-voting for this meeting on Modern gov
fire safety Arrangements if you hear the
alarm leave the building immediately via
fire exit and make your way to the
assembly point which is Ipswich Town
Football ground
follow the signs directly
to the fire exits at each end of the
floor do not onto the atrium ground
floor area on walkways if you're in the
atrium at the time of the alarm follow
the signs to the nearest fire exit use
the stairs do not lose the lifts do not
re-enter the building until told it is
safe to do so
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be recorded except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded by entering this meeting as a
speaker you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those sounds recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film or photograph
or broadcast this meeting when the
public and the Press are not lawfully
excluded
thank you Chet thank you Claire I'd like
to make the introductions for this
morning we have Ian Dupree a legal
advisor good morning chairman ladies and
gentlemen we have our chief planning
officer Mr Philip Isbell
good morning Chad thank you we have
Claire Philpot our government's officer
Robert Carmichael our governance officer
and for this particular one this morning
we have Vincent Pierce for the first
communication and Catherine Hale for the
second application is the case offices
uh see James James not with us yet
um thank you
right can I move to the agenda please
apologies for absence and substitutions
do you have any policy for absence no
chair thank you
to receive declarations peculiar or
non-pecure interest by members
councilor Parker
[Music]
yeah thank you chair
um in respect of dc21 and
00745 former slaughterhouse and land
adjacent to cuckoo Hill I will declare a
pecunery interest in the item chair as I
have a business arrangement with the
applicant's agent having received advice
from the monitoring officer and in the
interest of transparency for this item I
will withdraw from the debate and not to
take part in the vote I'll leave the
chamber thank you thank you Council
Parker
right
you've all received nearly minutes from
two one well yes
pl215 meeting to the meeting held in
June 16th of June are there any points
of accuracy on any of the pages
nope because I have a proposal please to
accept the minutes
I said Busby secondly
councilor beer
have you planned for the vote thank you
chair members if you select the plus
sign on your mortgage app
the vote for this item will now show in
light blue in progress
thank you members chair that's ten votes
for and one abstention that's carried
thank you
have been confirmed and will be signed
at the end of this meeting
to receive notification of petitions and
according to the council's petition
scheme
number
psych inspections are there any requests
for site visits
no right moving on schedule a planning
applications we will begin with
dc210745 former slaughterhouse and lands
adjacent to cook Hill Fearless Saint
Mary thank you councilor Parker
before we can can I just confirm with
councilor Barrett who is the war member
we'll be staying as part of the
committee
uh yes chair intend to stay Thank you
very much
I will know about the case officer
Vincent Pierce to introduce the
applications
uh chairman if I may step in at this
point
um you have uh some table papers which
in the usual way were circulated in
advance of this meeting uh officers have
included within that and an amended
recommendation and we did at that point
in time when we circulated those papers
uh advised that we may yet further
adjust the recommendation we have been
taking advice from Council who was
involved in representing Us in the
enforcement appeal and that has led us
to slightly tweak further the
recommendation and we are going to share
that recommendation to you at the start
of the presentation and and then we will
talk to it in specific terms line by
line at the conclusion the presentation
chairman so perhaps if we can circulate
that now and that will allow some
consideration as we as we go through the
presentation thank you Jim
okay
thank you Phil
yes can you hear me now yeah thank you
um just to be clear
will they do I've got some questions on
that page of hand of drone will we be
able to put the questions to you during
the course of the presentation or are we
waiting until
at the end or when you come in next
chairman for Simplicity it might be best
to take questions on the recommended
conditions at the end but I am quite
happy to take them to film as we go it
wouldn't wish there'd be any confusion
about which papers we're looking at
though and that might mean taking them
at the end will be prudent
okay so we'll be taking him at the end
thank you
okay moving on Vincent
thank you chair good morning members
ladies and gentlemen may I just check
before I start that interested members
of the public and anyone here for this
item do have a copy of the
updated papers
no I'm getting some
sorry Jeff would you wish to give Our
Guest a few moments to read that before
I start I'm in your hands dear
Mr chairman sorry another point of
clarification
um we have concerned residents I assumed
in the room uh have they seen a copy of
this latest paper that we were handed
earlier have they got copies of it
because you're only handed them that is
the chairman of the parish council which
is understandable
one at a time
have we papers available for the members
of the public
with the members of public like to see
their papers that have been tabled this
morning
and not will be sufficient
you've got them
there's a chairman coming I mean we do
intend to and I believe Vince has this
within his presentation that we intend
to happen on screen and talk to them
line by line when we get there
and to be able to
yes Mr chairman just that um in the
interest of um transparency I thought
you know they've been omitted but
they've overseen them or they're
prepared to see them on the screen
that's right we're safe thank you thank
you are we all set
Vincent George thank you chair as you
say we're looking at uh section 73
variation of condition
application for the site that was once
known as The Slaughterhouse on Cuckoo
Hill
now known as apple tree Muse it's a full
report
yeah but I will need to go through
certain elements in some detail
as we've just said I would ask members
to
refer to the latest updated paper as we
go through the
presentation
a series of
that doesn't seem to be moving
oh it isn't okay sorry
apologies
since the report was written we have
received amended drawings
on yesterday's table papers I refer to a
shifting of a dormer
in the rear roof slope of the house on
plot 5 it has gone to the other roof
slope
and I did include a drawing showing that
that was particular particular interest
to the occupiers of eversley
they've done my window now is not on the
side of the roof that looks towards
eversley we'll look at that in a moment
we have very recently received drawings
which show a significant reduction in
the garden level particularly on plot
six
which is of particular interest to the
occupiers of White Horse house I'll go
in into detail on what that means and
the implications of that
firm that in terms of the amended Garden
drawing that has been shared with the
occupiers of White Horse house I did
meet on site on Friday
the usual caveat that this presentation
is merely to supplement the content of
the report
so we're in some viewers and Mary which
I'm sure most of you will know is right
on the border between Suffolk and
Essex
reached by the b1508 from
from Essex
sitting across the river stir
beers Hamlet
application societies to the north east
of the village
the red line shows the site of the
overall development that is now known as
apple tree Muse
the history is fully set out in the
report in terms of appeals and
enforcement notice and we do have the
benefit of having Simon
Bailey with this morning our enforcement
manager who was clearly instrumental in
part of the appeal case and any
subsequent follow-up
what we're looking at this morning is
the two or the two biscuit colored
plots on that plan just so that members
are familiar with the surrounding
context we have white horse house here
in purple
six cuckoo Hill
seven cuckoo Hill
eversley
Byron house
and Pilgrim's garage
we're not this morning looking at plots
one two three and four
what we are looking at as I say is plot
five and plot six so you can immediately
see the most affected neighbors are
pilgrims garage White Horse house six
and seven cuckoo Hill and eversley and
we have had representations from the
occupyre of Byron house
it's the aerial shot of the side as it
exists at present
Lots five and six
and then adjoining properties
It's a Long View looking to the
Northeast
[Music]
view looking South towards friends field
in the open
land Beyond
we have a very short section of video
that actually Mandy you might have to
operate the switch to click to the
bottom left of that image
click the
go button on the video
no
[Music]
so here I am walking up the access rotor
for previews you'll notice the
rough surface of the track at that time
on the right you'll see a blue line I'll
refer to that in a moment
in front of us we have problems that's
Byron House on the Left
six
and that just Springs around and there
you can just see White Horse house in
the background and back towards the
track Pilgrim's Garage on that on the
right
the report fully sets out the
requirements of the outstanding
enforcement notice so I won't go into
detail on on that what we're looking at
this morning is do the proposed I would
say significant modifications to the two
dwellings
by the requirements of the inspector
when she upheld the enforcement notice
I think we also need to think about do
the Amendments deliver a solution to the
issues identified
by the inspector
but you know you in a different way so
the inspector required the buildings to
be demolished so that the ground level
could be reduced to the level that was
approved
this proposal doesn't result in the
ground level of the buildings being
adjusted what it does do is result in a
reduction in the height of the buildings
but at the level at which they have been
built at and of course we always have to
look at the individual merits of the
application
I think I need to say that since the
appeal the appellants have taken on new
consultants and we have worked with
those Consultants to come up with the
scheme that will be before you
the present consultant has no connection
with whatever went on before so
he has brought fresh eyes to the to the
matter
so these are the as built drawings if
you went out there today what you would
see
for plot five is that the black dashed
line is a line that has been marked on
the building
to show
what should have been the height of the
building and that
line was checked and inspected on a
joint site visit with Simon Bailey who
would confirm
that that is an accurate representation
of what should have been so the one on
the left shows you where the gables
should have been and the ridge
and the one on the right
actually shows you
where the eaves will be
will you to approve
the application before you
there's another shot that's the rear of
plot five
as is
plus six
front and back notice the first floor
windows
that looks directly towards White Horse
house
this gives you an idea of proximity of
the back of plot six
to the rear of Whitehorse house and the
garden
to White Horse house the garden
effectively is to the side of White
Horse house and sits behind that fence
where the two arrows are
the first issue I want to look at is
distance from the boundary and you'll
notice from the report that plot 5 was
built closer to the rear boundary
than approved and that is
0.81 meters closer
so on the image on the right is
the blue is where it has been located
the red image is where it should have
been
so there is an issue of
by building it closer that has caused
some harm to the amenity of eversley and
six and seven
cuckoo Hill
as I say this scheme does not
result in the footprint being moved so
why are we recommending approval despite
that
so
here we have the building plot 5 as
approved and the two vertical blue lines
are where the sash windows are at first
floor looking to the right so they're in
the rear elevation
what's been built
superimposed over the top
is that so the rich height is 1.07
meters higher than it should have been
and the rear elevation is 0.81
closer to the neighbors than it should
have been
so what we have shown in red is the
extent to which it varies from the
approved scheme
this drawing in the pale blue
superimposes what is now proposed on top
of what's been built
and you'll notice there are no windows
at first floor that's the two crosses
the ridge height is no higher than it
should have been had it been built as
approved
so the only difference
is that
so we're looking at
proximity extra proximity by 0.81
if we look at the two
outlines the one on the left shows you
as built
the one on the right shows you what is
now proposed and how it sits no higher
than what was approved
even though the ground level is higher
the whole first floor and roof has been
reduced so as not to exceed what was
approved
had it been built in the in the right
place and at the right height
part of our argument of saying that the
not pushing the building back is
acceptable is
the fact that the height reduction and
the changes to the rear elevation have
made a significant difference in terms
of protecting the amenity of Neighbors
in my professional opinion
so what does the proposal now consist of
well it involves removal of both roofs
it involves the demolition of a
significant part of the first floor to
each property
it involves replacing the roofs with
lower Eaves and Ridge
removing first floor windows in both
properties at the rear lowering the
garden
we've had a commitment to repair the
Garden Wall and end wall of White Horse
house which were damaged during the
construction process
we are looking to surface that section
of well not we as a council but the
applicant is through the permission if
one is granted surfacing the access road
the one that you saw that was pitted
pothole and and wearing away and also
resolving drainage issues
quick overview
very faint but I have got better
drawings the red is as built
and the green is
as approved and that just simply
demonstrates the added height the eaves
height is also higher
here we have a cross section through
plot six and you'll recall from the
appeal this is a highly contentious
element of the scheme so the red dashed
line
represents
as built
blue
is where it will be now what we haven't
got here is a true cross-section showing
the garden levels and I have a much
better
much better drawing of that in a moment
so where I've got that red rectangle the
levels there aren't shown
as they were in the report
just to emphasize the point about moving
the Dormer
that's where it was on plot five it's
now on that side so you can see it's
away from the
the boundary towards eversley
so that's the yellowed flashing doorman
now eversley's to the
the right of that picture and you'll
notice there are no windows at first
floor there's no Prospect now that one
in the middle is a staircase so there is
no Prospect of overlooking from bedrooms
at first floor
the scheme that was approved
had it been built and were it to be
rebuilt
following full demolition would have
windows at first floor
the ridge height is now reduced
the Eve's height is reduced and the
Gable height is reduced
so the view is now only possible in that
direction there's the dormal window in
the side of the Gable
it's where it was
and in terms of Outlook that Dormer will
now look towards
block six away from eversley so anyone
in the bedroom in that position in plot
5 will be looking at the roof of plot
six
I put this on just to show that were you
able to see anything out of that Dormer
towards White Horse house it would be
completely oblique and at a distance
that shouldn't pose any overlooking
issue
these are measurements that I've taken
from the drawing they probably appear in
the
report
but that shows on the left
as built on the right as
proposed and you can see there's a
significant difference in scale
in a nutshell that's the difference when
you look at the rear of plot 5 were you
were to prove this permission and it be
implemented the one on the left is what
would be rebuilt
the one on the right is what currently
exists
our argument is that the one on the left
is actually more sympathetic to
protecting amenity than the
one on the right even if the whole thing
is demolished and rebuilt at
somewhere in the region of 0.81 meters
higher
prove that
the difference so the red outline
demonstrates here the reduction in
height notice the significant reduction
in the garage height the inspector
didn't really comment on what the garage
position is but we have secured a
significant reduction in the garage
Heights as well
so the cable has dropped
on the black line
the eaves level is now reduced the blue
line
clearly the windows have gone
and there's now a dormer on that slope
effectively that's what would happen if
you approved
this application
all of that would be demolished
the windows will be taken out
and a new first floor and roof will be
put onto the building
so that's as built and you can see
if that was simply demolished and
rebuilt what would happen is you would
get that effect
so you still would have those first
floor Windows looking out towards the
back you would still have a high garage
roof
there it is again in summary
not six
that's what you see at the moment
standing in the rear Garden
effectively what will happen is
the piecing green is retained everything
above is demolished
there you have that
representation there
the red wire outline is where where
you'd have proved this application the
building would sit compared to what
exists
so we have white horse house in the
front
and you'll notice how much lower
the red outline is and remember this
also loses the first floor windows so in
terms of a transition this is what
would happen
if we play that again
in terms of the Dormer that's the
direction that it would look towards
Pilgrim's garage away from White Horse
house but if members felt even the
slightest risk of overlooking from that
window might be an issue for the
residents
what we could do
subject to your consideration will be
for that bottom element to be obscured
glass
fixed the only openable part of the
window being
at peace
that would provide even greater
protection for the occupiers of White
Horse house when they are in their their
Garden
that's the difference on the left is
where you to approve the application
before you on the right is what
currently exists and again it's the same
scenario as with
block five
at the front and here I'm thinking
particularly about the occupies of Byron
house
Ridge height clearly has come down as as
would be the case from the back
Eve types dropped
garage roof dropped
so here you see Byron house what's one
and six
really is a
blue angle
so the one the image at the top is what
exists the one at the bottom is what
would be built
where you need to Grant planning
permission so everything has been
lowered
and that's Byron house and the blue line
indicates where that photograph was
taken from
in terms of contamination whilst it's
not a matter before you as part of this
proposal I do just quickly want to um
update you on that
condition seven which was attached to an
earlier application has now been
discharged in terms of the contamination
remediation and certification on plot
one two three and four we have held back
on issuing an approval on plus five and
six
pending what happened
today so if planning permission is
granted we would then require
certification of any extra work that's
carried out
and that will be checked by Simon and
his team particularly the contaminated
land officer currently the site is fine
but if they're going to do some extra
excavation or bring your material in or
whatever it is we just want that to be
certain that that's inert
in terms of drainage again not part of
this proposal but because drainage is
such a contentious
issue in the era we have sought to come
up with some solutions that we could if
members wished and remind you to Grant
plenty permission attach a condition to
this proposal to deliver
full drainage solutions that we have
worked up with the agent
we've had confirmation from Suffolk
County highways and their Estates team
and the suds team that the solution is
acceptable
to them were members minded to Grant
consent
so what we're looking at is that is the
proposed foul sewage system
surface water shown in blue and what
you'll notice is
that the majority of that development
will drain into
that which is an attenuation tank
largely under Underground
and then that would release that water
on this pipe into a drain in the street
in cuckoo Hill
so all of these properties drain into
that tank
as you start to come down the slope
there are two gullies here and what is
now proposed to be a new channel drain
and I'll demonstrate what the effect of
of that we have had some video recently
of water coming down this slope onto
cuckoo Hill clearly wherever you've got
a slope and it rains you are going to
get some water coming down the the slope
but there are gullies there's a gully
here there's another one here and a lot
of this water will now be intercepted
down to that that point
which is a much better situation than
existed
before
when I need to just quickly demonstrate
here
so also the
applicant has agreed and there's
evidence of of that
to connect the land drain within
eversley's Garden to their system
first it has to be located
but I understand that is something that
the occupiers have ever sleep were
anxious to have resolved
and so we can include conditions to that
effect where you might need to Grant
planning permission
this is only my own mock-up of how the
system will work but
it explains the principles so here on
the left we have the attenuation tank
that's taking all the surface water from
plots one to just
the
the big
big breakthrough if it's if we can think
of it as a breakthrough is the
installation of a Hydra break
which will restrict outflow from this
tank to 5 liters per second
that is a green field runoff rate
at the moment
that flow is unrestricted and it was
unrestricted previously
so now we have introduced
a regulatory mechanism to prevent
flesh flow from coming down into the
system
so what happens is
that Hydra break will release water from
the tank at five liters per second
into the drain
even were there to be a surge of water
into the tank let's say during a
particularly heavy rainy period
the Hydra break would still release it
at five liters per second the capacity
of the tank is sufficient to accommodate
the extra water
and that's the key to we think key to
success of getting surface water
adequately dealt with on this this site
at the moment there's a raised Gully on
the slope so clearly that can't accept
much water at the minute because it's
above the level of the the road the road
isn't finished
in that position there there'd be a
a channel drain so that's a sort of slit
across the road with the iron grid over
the top that connects to the surface
water system so any water coming down
here will will enter the channel drain
and then be piped
under that surface to the system in
cuckoo Hill
again that's intercepting a lot of
potential flow that would otherwise have
gone down the slope
you can see here the surface at that
point so we've got Pilgrim's garage on
the right you can see where water has
worn away the
is wearing away the exposed Earth
what we're suggesting is as a condition
of that
that entire section of surface be
effectively resurfaced properly with a
with a hard wearing
surface probably tarmac might be
concrete
an issue that as a risen since this
development started
for pilgrims garages I've been in and
looked at the inspection pit within that
garage and what happens reported by
Jeremy Oxford the
the proprietor is particularly after a
weekend it's been raining at the bottom
of his inspection pit he gets about
three or four inches of water that had
never that and never happened before
it doesn't look as though that water is
going down the slope
let's go back one so we can see it
doesn't look as though the water is
shooting down here
and then dropping down his own slope
into the garage because he's got quite a
high lip in here
what we think is happening is that the
water table is actually risen whether
that's because of the development or
whether it's because the drainage
surface drainage system is not finally
installed
we think his inspection page is probably
something like 40 years old and he's
probably not tanked so it's not
waterproofed so if they
if the water level has risen he's
actually getting water permeating
through the wall of his inspection pit I
know the um the agent for the
application is going to send out a
drainage engineer but in truth I don't
think there's anything we can do as part
of this application to
to help Mr Oxford
certainly resurfacing the road and
putting the drainage in will stop any
water
pouring down his own
access to his his garage but he also has
a drain here and as I say there's a lip
and according to Mr Oxford
he doesn't think water is is coming in
through that point
but I do want to explain that because it
is an issue that has come up but I think
that's out with the scope of this
application
in terms of rear boundaries this is a
shot
at the bottom of White Horse house in
the garden there is a block work wall
the fence sitting on top of it and
that's just my tape measure to
demonstrate
Heights now we don't need to see what
they are because I've got a drawing but
so those heights were agreed by an
occupier of White Horse house
the agent and myself
but what is clear you can see this large
crack in the wall within White Horse
house
you'll see that there have been attempts
to try and hold back the pressure of the
soil behind it
what's happening is that piece of the
wall is moving away from the wrist but
what you'll notice on the right is that
wall is bowing out towards White Horse
house
so as part of this proposal we now have
a commitment to repair replace that wall
both this side and behind me the summer
house to make good the damage that has
been caused to that wall
part of the solution is to remove the
soil that's been built up against the
back of that
wall
there's the shot so we're looking on the
other side of that fence
Timber things here
is the
block work rule below it behind that
so what the occupiers of White Horse
house have experienced is the addition
of this fence
and I can stand at this point on the
bottom of the garden and admittedly I'm
taller than most but I can clearly see
over the top of that fence where I'm not
six foot four
I could still see over the top of that
that fits so clearly these levels had
been adjusted
the fence had been put up to provide
some privacy but in fact it doesn't do
the the job now the good thing with the
solution of lowering the garden level is
potentially this fence can be removed
so that restores some of the amenity of
the occupiers of White Horse house when
they're in the garage in their Garden
because they don't have this 2.77 meter
high
structure at the bottom of their their
Garden
so let's just
in
so at the moment it's 1.66
that piece of plywood is actually
covering a hole
in which you can now see
the extent to which the manhole was
raised
there's a manhole under that that takes
part of White Horse houses found sewage
system
there's the hole
you can actually see the original ground
level
so this is what I measured on site so
here I am this is White Horse house
here's the block work wall
and here's the fence on top
this soil here appears to have been
raised all of this represents raised
levels it would appear
what is now being proposed is to remove
that
and because this now drops this piece of
fence can be removed
and the occupiers here can enjoy their
Garden without being
overlooked
at a higher level
so moving
there I am and I can look over that
this plan shows effectively what will
happen and plan form
and this is this is the all-important
corner so here there's a little summer
house for White Horse house here's the
wall with the blockwork wall this is a
brick wall with some damage to it as
well all of this will be excavated out
gravel will be put in around the drain
and this is a additional retaining
this is now a deck patio there will be
stepped down to this area of garden
so that is what would happen
in the event that members were minded to
Grant this permission for this
application so here you have this patio
area this piece is now terraced with a
retaining more Garden drops down back to
the original level here's the blood work
wall
a far less dominating solution that has
caused the occupiers of
White Horse house considerable distress
particularly with this high fence on it
as well
and a close-up
more shots of the fencing as we go
around
I just want to draw your attention
members here so here's a piece of
plaster that was left on the back wall
of White Horse house when demolition was
occurring here
so this is part of White Horse house if
we just look over that fence what we can
actually see is some of the damage that
was left
when buildings on the old industrial
site were being demolished these are the
bits that will be repaired
and the rear elevation will be restored
to good order
were you Monday to ground planning
permission
just to point out that that you have
ever sleep two windows here there are no
windows in the rear elevation at first
floor of eversleep
and this is where the Dormer will now be
on this side
just looking around from the backup
plot five there's obviously there are
the windows and then we're looking here
towards the back of
seven six
cuckoo Hill
White Horse house
so what we've been looking for in terms
of the agreement
that would accompany any permission
where you might either Grant it would be
something that
provides an agreed
schedule of Works telescope that time
down to the minimum level necessary to
achieve
the complete rebuilding
and restoration of the ground
but we're also looking for a financial
bond that would enable the council to do
the work in default
were for whatever reason the applicant
unable or unwilling to start or finish
the modification works the council could
step in and do it
and draw down on the 250 000 pound Bond
that would sit in a secure
account
and that would save the public post
clearly we might have been able to put
it down on put it as a land charge and
to try and secure it at some point in
the future
my feeling is that members would would
want to be able to do the work quickly
this would provide the mechanism for
doing that work quickly without having
to dip into the council's own funds were
the work to cost more than that then we
would recover the additional cost by
putting a charge on the land
so at this point members we will the
recommendation will be as set out in the
paper that was circulated
today
and in order to provide
Clarity I will go through that
in in a little detail so what we are
suggesting is that you give delegated
authority to the chief planning officer
to Grant conditional planning permission
subject to the prior completion of an
appropriate signed
binding legal agreement and that
agreement must be to his satisfaction
and it must deliver all of the following
elements
so the first is a financial Bond
to the tune of quarter of a million
pounds
that must be provided by a third party
that is approved by the council's
finance team
this is nothing unusual in terms of
development securing a bond is something
that happens all the time you'll be
familiar members with
Suffolk County Council the highway
service always secures a bond when the
highway works are being undertaken in
case they have to step in
foreign
but also this this Bond will be
available to the council upon default
and we would expect to be able to draw
on that immediately that happened
so there are no ifs and buts it's
default and we start using the money
were we minded to do so
let's jump
the agreement would require the owner
developer applicant and successor in
title if it changed hands
to do all the works in the work schedule
that includes the garden reduction
in accordance with an agreed 30-week
build program that includes preparation
demolition rebuild completion
that 30 weeks would commence
from effectively the signing of that
agreement and the issue of planning
permission
it will include the garden lowering
which is a an important and late
um extra benefit that we have managed to
secure with the aid of the the agent and
the the applicants
the agreement must include the repair of
the wall or its replacement the White
Horse house it must include
commitment to and the undertaking of
repairs to the damaged rear wall
it must include a right of entry for the
council to go on the land and do the
work in default
and it must include the ability for the
council to then charge for additional
work beyond the quarter of a million
through
registering it
on on the title
the council also must be given a say in
any attempt to transfer the land
because obviously we would then be
chasing a different party
so what we have tried to do and we have
taken count cell opinion is come up with
as robust a system as possible
for ensuring that we're the work not to
occur we would be in a position to to
step in
and do it
we have we believe that the developer is
anxious to proceed with the modification
work if planning permission is granted
today but what we're saying is that can
only happen if that agreement has been
secured in advance
what could happen of course is
the developer could be required to
demolish both buildings by the 26th of
August as is required by the enforcement
notice the developer would then be
perfectly able to rebuild those two
properties
but at the level approved so let's
argument say a lower a meter lower
but he could rebuild effectively what's
there at the moment it would just be a
meter lower
so we've also set out suggested
conditions
in that
tabled paper that has been circulated
today that will include the removal of
all permitted development rights so at
some future date we couldn't have people
adding extensions raising the roof
putting new Dormers in adding Windows
putting sheds up even because a shared
on the boundary could cause problems for
Neighbors so even that would have to
come to us for approval
putting extra fencing up that too would
also need up our permission
so what we've tried to do through the
conditions is actually secure and tie
down as tightly as we can
future changes because they could have a
serious impact on the humanity of
Neighbors
so in essence members what we are
recommending to you is as I've just
described set out on today's table
papers and just to leave you with a
before and after or you might need to
Grant planning permission that's a
summary of the position in terms of the
impact at the rear of both of those
plants so on the left is what is now
proposed on the right is what has been
built
thank you chair
thank you Vincent thank you for the very
comprehensive report
um
questions from members for the officer
are there any
Council Jameson would you like to go
first uh thank you chair it's just a
question I'm not sure if the opposite
can answer this but it's regarding the
Heritage aspects I made the Heritage
team have no objection to the proposal
yet um on previous applications on now
and both here and my own area the
Heritage object to much more much less
intrusive
um development this one which is really
close I think the White House house is
listed they've got no objections but I
wondered what what you can clarify why
that is
thank you chair certainly councilor
Jameson it is a good point and I
actually appeared as the council's
witness in terms of the Heritage and
conservation elements at the inquiry
when the permission was originally
granted what was on the site were a
series of unsightly industrial buildings
and at the time there was considered to
be significant benefit to the Heritage
assets to see all of those unsightly
buildings removed
and effectively what was approved was
the residential scheme so at the inquiry
the position for the inspector and all
the parties was what we have is an
existing permission for residential
permission development in proximity to
White Horse house which is great to
listed
the issue for us now is does the scheme
that's before you represent
an improvement in terms of the impact on
the listed building and Conservation
Area compared to the permission that
exists
another view is another view of our our
other Heritage colleagues is that it's
actually an improvement over what was
approved and what could be built and
it's certainly an improvement over what
has been built and that's largely
because
scale has
has come down it's less imposing in
terms of its impact it is less visible
it's I'm not trying to pretend you can't
see it because that would clearly be
ridiculous but it isn't as prominent as
what has been built and what would be
built
were it to be rebuilt in the right
position so there are actually
improvements
so the question is previously there was
considered to be less than significant
harm which as you know is still
significant but what you then do is
weigh out the benefits against the harm
to the Heritage Essex what we now have
is a situation that's an improvement
over what could be built
in terms of the impact on the listing
building and the Conservation Area
okay councilor beer would you like to
awesome
thank you Mr chairman um
I've got about 11 questions but I'm not
going to ask how many 11 but I'm not
asking them all now because I think some
of them will come up and debate yeah and
others may ask anyway one came to the
Jameson but there's three I particularly
want just clarification on
slide 32
if you can get that back up
is obviously what we can call a planning
game is that not correct
because it's been reduced now
um to something that is possibly more
acceptable
because it's lower
sorry cancel the bureau I'll just wait
for Mandy to
well 32 to 35 I think it is
yeah
whether it's planning gain it's
certainly an enhancement perhaps I would
use a different word it's an enhancement
over what could be built it's not a gain
in the sense of section 106 type thank
you but it is certainly an enhancement
and one that provides
added amenity to adjoining occupiers and
helps the character of the listing
building constellation area so yes it's
the answer thank you so
following on on that
if we were still minded to refuse this
presumably the applicant can would be
required if you wanted to continue to
build what was originally approved by
this committee is that correct
because I think my point a better follow
this bit on is that if we refused it is
there any possibility
that future discussions could continue
where we could get something smaller and
lower like Bungalows because these
although you're reducing them are still
two-story
and then I write that originally this
was approved way back in the history
2015 under delegation Powers I want that
clarified as well
when I would say
there is if
used
the applicant has the ability
well will be required to demolish both
buildings
having demolished them he he or they are
perfectly able then to rebuild both
structures
but but at a ground level that's been
reduced
it will remain a two-story building with
windows at first floor looking out
towards
eversley six seven cuckoo Hill and white
horse house
if it were refused then we might as well
grab the ball by the horns and and point
out that the applicant would have a
right of appeal
and that who knows what would happen
there but our feeling as officers is
that because the issues identified the
inquiry
and have been drawn out in terms of the
inspector's decision
we've actually ended up with a position
that he's better for Neighbors than what
was approved had it been built in the
right position
I do not believe we're in a position to
negotiate a bungalow because effectively
we have the fullback position of the
earlier consent that these are 4a2 story
building
now I'm trying to recall whether it was
a delegated decision or not I
can't record I would need to check
because
chat from memory it was before my time I
think that it I think it was a committed
decision but I don't want to obviously
the committee the purpose of them I will
check we will check and come back to you
but yeah okay
I think that's important that we do get
the correct answer to that thank you
um so the Bungalow part uh right
um my second one was to do between slows
69 and 76 which was to do with the the
land levels that the house
will be reduced and the land is going to
be taken away in in the garden you're
saying but surely the house has still
built on grounds levels that were raised
you have only lowered it on the garden
side and below the fence and so that you
can stand at the bottom and you won't
see over there
their property the White House
is that correct I understand them right
let me explain it perhaps with a
the aid of this
and this so here here's what's been
built yeah and it's that much higher
than it should be yep
what's being proposed
is something that does that
but still on the same height the level
of the land was raised and that yeah the
level of the land was raised
here it is
what's being put back at that level
still brings it
down to the level of the building had it
been built in the right place
what happens is in the garden there's a
patio then you drop down
and then you go to the fence
so the fact that the house was built on
Ray's land isn't an issue
correct
the height of
the over the building
correct right that surprised me thank
you and my last vacation here can we how
many more have you got no this is my
last one the rest are coming up uh
they'll come later
um the 26th of August sorry I was
writing and I didn't hear what you said
have they got to do demolish this by the
26th of August or start the demolishment
to be demolished by the 26th of August
but I will look to my colleague Simon
Bailey just to
I get the nod yeah it has to be
completed by then
Jim before we have counselor
can Chief thing obviously wants to have
a work sorry thank you chairman yes I
appreciate that just to pick up on the
point that you raised there Council of
beer I think it's referred to in the
decision as the underbuild we are not
changing the ground levels of the land
on which the building the houses sit we
are changing we're talking about the
change in the levels within the garden
and the important Point as with any
planning application is the unacceptable
harm that may arise
so we're looking at that rather than the
fact that they may or may not have been
changes in land level because we are
comparing now the harm that may arise
from this or absence of it and the
impact and consequences of the planning
permission which the developer could
revert back to having
complied with the notice and you will
understand from experience that
compliance with the notice expected in
in August
is not a guarantee it is an expectation
and if that is not complied with then
one may foreseeably end up having to
pursue the matter through the courts and
almost endless permutations of how that
might happen we are ready to do it but
that is how this would be
I think it comes to be it Council engine
thank you Mr chairman
um
this water runoff system this wonderful
tank that only allows water out of flows
of five liters a second or whatever it
is
when it comes out of that tank it goes
into a pipe which comes down the
Drive the access route
but according to page 26 of the report
the county councils assets manager
drainage and soft Estates doesn't seem
to think there's anywhere for it to go
to where is it actually going to go to
when it goes down there or is it just
going to be allowed for somebody else's
problem a bit further downhill
and secondly if we lower the level of
the garden
to comply with the original Planning
Commission further to what councilor
beer said really are we not exposing the
foundations and therefore making the
property not comply with
current building regulations in terms of
the footings don't actually go down into
the ground as far as they're supposed to
go down into the ground because we then
could eventually effectively be creating
a house that will be liable to
effectively tip over into White Horse
house
foreign
first well I'll start with the second
Point first
because the building will not be
demolished for you to Grant permission
the fact that
it sits on the foundations that have
been built and some of the garden is
being excavated doesn't mean the
foundations will be exposed because I
can't remember what slide it was Mandy
but
from that cross section you'll notice
there's a an area around
the house that is not being excavated a
significant area behind the house will
be
laid out as patio already there is an
element of patio and then there will be
a retaining wall and then the garden
will be escalated so there is no risk of
Foundations
being exposed and
we have every confidence that the
building's not going to collapse as a
result of
any of the modification works
in terms of the drainage issue you are
absolutely right the report did make it
clear that the County council did have
concerns about the drainage system
connecting to
their system but since then and reported
through the updated papers
the County Council and the agent and
other parties have had cameras down the
drainage system
and the County Council is now satisfied
that the pipe can be connected to their
system
particularly with the Hydra brake system
in which would regulate the
outflow at five liters per second
because currently and previously there
was no restriction
so in terms of the County council with
the extra surveying work that's been
undertaken they are satisfied that it's
actually improved an improvement
to the drainage situation their system
can cope with it it has been coping with
it but now it will be regulated in a way
that it hasn't before
so since the report was written we've
had that extra piece of um
analysis and we have actually formally
had the response from County Council
they are now satisfied
yeah one more Mr chairman I think it
does come back on that I I know what
he's like having cameras stuck in both
places just recently that's another
story
um
so there was an existing pipe
connected to the County Council
stormwater drainage system because the
report says that they are not allowing
any new connections so if it doesn't
connect to the stormwater system what
does it connect to
it was connected to their system and as
you know Council intern there are lots
of examples where all sorts of
connections are made to systems that
perhaps haven't been authorized but over
time they just
they just happen and that's what seems
to have happened here because they've
been accepting the flow for it appears
many years
they now say well they can't resist it
because it already exists
but what they can now take comfort from
Is That Flow will now be regulated in a
way that it was never regulated before
councilor Owen
oh yeah
um I noticed about the sheds and
everything but I didn't notice that
um about decking would you put a stop on
decking going into the garden because
that does rise up quite well
absolutely the condition we're
suggesting would stop all of that sort
of work
Dr Jensen you had one more
yeah yeah thank you chair just go back
to something the chief clothing officer
alluded to a moment ago
or have a misunderstood you you said
that if we reminded to refuse this
application and the applicant doesn't
comply with the
um the recommendations we would then
have to pursue they've been caught and
Colts could corpse over certain the
appeal decision
of a misunderstood
chairman if I if I may I'll try and
explain and
Bailey correct me when I get the
enforcement position wrong
um
the decision you make on this
application
um if you refuse it will not alter the
enforcement notice requirements and
compliance will be expected in August
uh if compliance is not evident on a
date in August then one of the options
we have or all enforcement is experience
we would expect to pursue the matter
either and direct action is one
possibility uh in Junction there are
various other remedies available through
the courts
clearly we would have to take an action
in court and take legal advice on it and
I'm not going to pre-judge any of those
considerations
um that none of that would alter the
outcome of the enforcement notice which
is binding and binds all successes in
title
but it doesn't actually make the works
happen you would in effect have a
decision which would then have to be
given effect to somehow and one option
is direct action but then you've got to
recover your costs if you do that
so you've got a series of potential
courses of action which Maya and why not
play out and
the decision here you can appeal but
that frankly is irrelevant to the course
of the enforcement progress
except to the extent that if we pursue
an enforcement
action through the courts in relation to
something and the courts
have regard to the appeal in mitigation
if it's argued in mitigation the courts
might choose to say we will stay action
pending the determination of that appeal
that's one possibility but literally
it is not a it is not a break on giving
effect to the enforcement notice
and the compliance expectation so the
fact that there is a right of appeal is
almost
from my perspective largely irrelevant
but it could be argued and a court might
choose to take account of it to stay
action pending the outcome and obviously
you're then in the hands of the
inspector's timetable for planning
appeals does that help
thank you
all right cash attention thank you
Council Busby
yeah it's the drainage thing that still
concerns me if you could go to slide I
think it's 60.
60 61 something like that
and and sort of then it's the effect of
digging the garden out
the one with the blue lines on it
here one of the laptop middle right
previous one
I'll assume control of this slides
hopefully why you've got that one on
there how big is the tank
I'd have to check I can't to be off the
top of my head
because five liters per second so that's
quite a lot of water it's a that's a
watering can fall every second I mean
it's going to get through quite a lot of
water
all right
must be the
that's it
so what we should be suggesting here is
that all those blue lines are going to
pump water into that
attenuation tank is that correct
yes
apart from obviously this section down
here right so if you look at the Blue
Line That's south of plot six and south
of plot five
like you've dug the garden Out Below
those lines
that's going to take some pretty nifty
pump work to get the water to flow
uphill rather than go into the gardens
and then presumably drain through to
white four thousand
houses six and seven
I mean it's going to be quite quite a
steep drop between the house and the
back of the garden and the water is
going to be tempted to go that way
rather than whatever you do in those
blue lines
not
I see where you're coming from and what
I would say is
cross-section because it isn't as the
slope isn't as you might imagine it
there's quite a steep a lot of slopes on
that although no I would
I don't disappear that
it's this
sorry
there yes so
it looks like a sinkhole no well okay
but this is obviously level this here is
not
it's not the Cresta
Cresta run what would happen is because
that's now at back at the ground level
previous ground level this would be
soaking into the
into this but that's all coming out
isn't it no sorry let me explain that at
the moment the ground level is here and
goes across
so at the moment this has got soil in
here
what will happen is that will all be
taken out
and the original or close to the
original ground level will be restored
so rain
there'll be no roof water coming off of
this because that's going in a pipe and
coming out out through the front
so rain falling on the garden will
simply percolate into the ground like
garden water does
so I haven't helped by
the way I described that so
picture in here councilor Busby this at
the moment is all soil in here
that will come out this is what's close
to the original ground level so rain
water will simply percolate into the
ground
any water falling here will run back
in a pipe to the tank
so I'm not totally convinced about this
the slope on that now I'm sure the slope
appears to be from my from the site
because it appears to be steeper than
that if if there was a particular uh
concern
as part of the drainage condition of
course we can
give extra consideration to
[Music]
this point
in the cross section so we can think
about and take expert advice on
will rainwater percolate into the soil
sufficiently to avoid a problem or do we
need something like a French drain or
some other solution at the bottom here
to pick up any surplus water that is
going down this modest slope quite happy
to pick that up through the okay I mean
certainly if you're going to replace the
wall which they are yeah no I can see
the point it ought to be waterproofed
tests and get some advice on whether or
not the garden can can cope with that if
not we'll look at a system known it
could be something like a French drain
where you just have a ditch and gravel
and it soaks away and it could be taken
up
particularly through the side wall and
come down onto the road but
be possible chair if members were minded
to
beef up let's call it beef up the
drainage congestion that I've suggested
I have somebody fire on your other
question
thank you Joe
um Vince this we've had a lot of
discussion about the technicalities of
all of this but for me there's a big
impact on people
and apart from the neighbors of this
development who obviously have had
difficulties with the development do we
know if there are
because when you had their new houses do
we know if this is impacted on people
who may have been about to purchase
these properties how have people being
dis other people being disadvantaged by
this development
thank you councilor I'm not aware of
anyone who might have been disadvantaged
in terms of purchasing
five and six
if
Barry Mr Weymouth wishes to make
representations on that I don't know
whether he'd know more than and I do he
may well not know
um we haven't had representations from
anyone who's bought
units plots one to four we certainly had
the representation from the occupier of
Byron house which is still a modern
property but
but not as recent as plots one to four
um
throughout my concern or my
what's Driven me is to try and find a
solution that actually represents
an enhancement
for Neighbors compared to what could be
built
with the approval that exists at a
different level because you're right
this development has had a significant
impact on on neighbors and that's why
genuinely is a professional planner I
feel that what we potentially have is a
better solution
for Neighbors it doesn't provide any
recompense for the anguish upset and
concern that that has been created
but I strongly believe that the position
would be better than what could be built
and that's the best I could do in the
the circumstances
okay okay perhaps you'd like to ask that
question of the agent as well when you
get a job thank you
councilor Baron
thank you
a couple of questions that I think it's
also from me um can you
um tell us what the distance now is from
plot 5 to eversley
if you have that
I should know it and we'll double check
it just so that I'm absolutely accurate
if you if I can have a little bit of
time after this is just to do some
measurements
and you have another question and yeah
just to follow on from some of your
points about the drainage
um this Hydro Break
um would it would it require pumping
uphill at from some of the plots to move
the water across
my understanding is there's no pumping
it all works through gravity
sure
because we have Mr Weimar with us who I
don't know whether he was intending to
speak
he nodding so we can ask or you can ask
Mr Weimar that but my understanding is
it it would all work through gravity
is because we've seen some of those cut
those cross-sections that you've done is
is that cross-section showing The Dugout
Garden perhaps a bit extreme in how
you've represented it because it looks
as though The Dugout part of plot six is
actually deeper than the garden of White
House White Horse house
which doesn't seem right because that
might undermine the boundary wall and
the foundations
I think we'll deal with your last
question first we will have to find that
cross-section
Wendy so
the wonders of
PowerPoint if you can find that
everyone oh there it is good
so
down to the Barrett
that's the point at which a garden will
be reduced on plot six so there it is at
the bottom of that wall just above my
Red Dot and there is the garden level
White Horse house so they're brawl
there's broad parity but it's still
slightly above
the garden and white horse house but at
the moment it is up here somewhere
so I'm satisfied that it isn't below it
and shouldn't be doing any undermining
well on the same picture uh slowly sorry
um and it's not a criticism but that is
totally mislead and certainly to me that
it looks as though that's the land level
and I agree with pencil Busby and
councilor Hinton that that looked like
that was all coming out I still can't
imagine where the
existent land level is now
and to automate you're dropping it down
there okay because if it doesn't go down
that
in that sort of um
back a bit I just can't imagine it I
think you've got to get that a bit
clearer for me to understand I'm sorry
I think I can do it
so
the red dashed line represents
a building as built so that's where the
roof is at the moment
ground level
this is where ground level was that
dashed line
that is where it has been
built up to now if you took that line
across
see
so what happened was
soil or other materials was built up
where my Red Dot is jiggling
and it it carried wrong
right across to the wall so it was at
that point so what is happening is
although the house will not be
demolished if you were to go on
permission and would sit at the level
that it's been built at
all of that where my Red Dot is
of sort of would come out
so the original level
um has built the original land level was
the data blind
and above there is all added but over on
the bubble bit that's coming out all
right I can now understand it thank you
very much
apologies Council for not making in that
clear
thank you thank you councilman you have
one more question
sorry it's still on the same point
because the the land was being dug out
so the people couldn't see over the wall
and I don't think the wall is two meters
high it was something less than that the
implication was that the land was going
to have to be dug out
so that it was lower
than a you know a six foot four person
standing on it couldn't see over the top
of that wall so there was going to be
quite a bit more that was going to be
dug out it wasn't just to take away the
excess soil that had been put there
it was to provide a service in terms of
lowering
the height or are you going to build a
taller wall which wasn't the
objective
the question or a statement
thank you I'm happy to answer the I'm
happy to answer the kind of question
chair with your
well
can you answer it sorry if I can assist
I think and I'm not wishing to criticize
things I think the wall that you've got
on that drawing is the wall that's right
next to the extension of the back of
White Horse house
whereas actually the wall that you're
talking about is the dog leg one which
is much further up and given that it's
much further up and close to 2.6 the
land level would be that much higher at
that point because it slopes down where
it's been built up
so with it being
higher in the first place then being
dropped down to the previous level would
make that much difference
I think that explains the point that
you're talking about so you're saying
that
if you're standing in your garden on
plot six at any point you won't be able
to see over the wall
into
that's the proposal
add a little bit of extra Clarity
because the condition what we're
acquiring is
that after excavation of the garden
were you to stand at any point on that
boundary it would be
1.8 meters
to the top of a wall
so 1.8 is the normal height that you
would expect a fence so when we asked
Simon and his team to go out because
what we're proposing is an inspection
regime where you'd Grant planning
permissions for key stages we would go
out and do measurements so before the
new roof was tiled we would go out and
measure the height to make sure it was
spot on we'd also factor in the point
that on top of the trusses you're also
going to have the ridge tiles and things
so one of the points that we would ask
our colleagues to check was the height
of the the ground level adjacent to the
wall and that must be at least 1.8
[Applause]
thank you chair just to come back on a
couple of other points as well for
councilor Barrett the distance between
plot 5 and eversley would be 10.4 meters
um the distance to the boundary for at a
point of reference the difference
distance to the boundary for six and
seven is 10.7 meters
to come back on councilor beers point
the original application went to
committee on the 27th of February 2015.
the first one yeah
thank you chair thank you
sorry say again the date again 27th of
Feb 15. okay thank you
Council Osborne you had a question
well it's not a question it's just a
um a position that I see on
1.3.7 where it shows uh from the
excavator and the man standing behind a
fence so that is the level as I see it
that the uh drop is going to make
because that white wall below it was the
original was the original height of the
wall so
also there's a drain that with the tanks
in it I think it's up with the tank and
that tank uh if you look down I think
you've already shown that one picture of
it where you see the actual lower level
of that land below the tank level so
that does that point out does that give
you a better look at the position of
that bins please that's a good point
councilor Osborne you're right but the
person in that image was either standing
on the cherry picker or standing on the
um
ply that's over the hole
if you can imagine that levels behind
that are going to be dropped to the
point where you won't need that Timber
fence and you still won't be able to see
that gives you an idea of the
significant
adjustment that will be made
yeah thank you Mr chairman yeah also I
mean we've had several site visits on
this as
as
as as we all know but
when we looked at this originally the um
existing level ground level was seen
quite quite
quite honestly from from the where the
drain was and we pointed that out and I
must say that what Simon has done and
what we looked on this site was it's it
looks as if everything has been looked
at in in good detail thank you thank you
Miss Jim
well yeah sorry well it's still
questions but counselor Busby did ask
um officer Vincent
um could you see from any point in that
garden over the fence if you were
standing on the decking
you would be higher than if you was at
the boundary fence so presumably you'd
be able to say over that walled
considerably or not I think that's the
question
because the patio or the decked area is
away from the fence effectively the
angles would would prevent you from
having an overlooking opportunity
[Music]
quick
question I think relating to
your slide 44
um it was I think there was a two slides
shown one with the roof
to the rear of plot six and then showing
what it make up of what it would like
without the with the reduced height but
it appeared that the
building
beside plot six don't totally
disappeared
it was that is that is that what you
anticipate would happen with the the
garage and the plot five
because
I didn't know whether you would just
demonstrate in part six reduction in
height and we would focus on that or
whether you were suggesting that plot
the the adjacent plot would also
completely disappear from you if we can
go to
yeah
that's a excellent
Point counselor and I'm glad I can have
the opportunity to make it clear
that was simply the um me trying to
highlight the impact on plot six and
you're quite right what I've actually
done is it makes it look as o5
disappears
it doesn't disappear so where you can
see let's do it this way well you can
see
plot 5 as built
oh apologies yeah so here we go here's
the garage and then
is over here because this is being
reduced as part of this when you do that
sorry
can't now get rid of them so what we're
looking at is plot four and six there
yeah so let's just and again
yeah
what I have unfortunately done and it I
promise you it wasn't
deliberately to mislead members is
[Music]
there will be an element of Garrett's
roof in here but because it's no longer
the very steep
roof it will disappear down through here
but yes
nothing's happening to the building in
the distance it's at plot four
so
an excellent spot and I'm glad that he
was able to
correct that thank you
okay no more questions
I think you nearly all have had a go
thank you right
thank you very much Vincent for that
thank you
moving on public speakers uh we were now
asked to Parish Council representative
Jill Jackson
speed for three about three minutes to
address the commission
okay thank you
the development of cuckoo Hill beers is
an issue that has caused more upset
annoyance protests and disturbance to
Residents than any building since the
1840s when the railway cut through the
village this gives you an idea of
significance of the problem
in November 2020 Diane Lewis inspector
appointed by the Secretary of State
dismissed Steve Mar's appeal and judge
the developer had used under build
without justification and cited houses
incorrectly the houses were built
without planning permission as a result
of being built incorrectly in the
inspector's words the effect on immunity
for existing and future residents of the
neighboring homes on Cuckoo Hill is
unacceptable
we maintain that if this application is
grounded the unacceptable impact will
remain
views Mary Parish Council supports the
neighboring residents and those from
across the whole village and Beyond in
believing that this development has
always been wrong and no changes to the
building make it right
we did not agree with the grounding of
permission from plots one to four and
clearly those properties were also built
without permission and with severely
detrimental effects on the neighborhood
properties
in 0.188 of her report the inspector
gave the developer a Way Forward other
than total Demolition and this is what
we've got before us today
the district council officers have kept
us informed and have asked our opinions
at all stages of this application and we
in turn have ensured that all points
raised by residents have been put
however there is a long history of
mistakes with this case an incontestable
harms remain
we all understand the basic tenet that
underpins the role of the planning
committee and that is that every
application must be determined on its
individual merits having regards raw
material planning considerations and
that's as stated in the recommendation
report
however given the tortuous history of
this case spanning several years
understandably the residents find it
impossible to look at this current
application afresh
we acknowledge that work by officers and
appreciate very much appreciate the
detailed questioning by the councilors
today
first and foremost the parish council
has a duty to represent its residence
and the parish council can see no other
honorable solution other than to
recommend the demolition of the houses
on plots five and six and the
restoration of the site to its original
level
thank you Mr chairman thank you very
much
would you take your sit down please take
questions away any questions for the
parish council
go and cancel a beer kick off
no no no well first thank you
um can I can I ask you
um you've you've heard the uh questions
backwards and falls about the height
if this committee was minded to continue
to oppose this and go for demolition
at the end of it it's been made clear to
us that they can
um build what was originally agreed in
um so you will still get a
dwelling there
do you not think that what's been
proposed
is better than what
if they went back to the original
planning which is what we all said we
wanted I understand that but this might
be a better compromise I'd like to know
what you think the feeling would be
thank you
a very difficult call
um councilor beer because the residents
as I've just made clear the residents
are finding it impossible to see things
in that way and we are here to represent
those views
thank you
any other questions
no in that case thank you very much
there is no objector or supporter but I
do have Barry Weimar who is the agent
for the proposal
thank you you're away good I think
that's on uh good morning chairman
members
um firstly I I would just like to
express my thanks and appreciation to Mr
Pierce and his team because it has been
a very difficult application to bring
through to this point uh partly with the
pandemic and having virtual meetings it
has been quite a challenge and I'm
pleased to see the very concise and
detailed report that Mr Pierce has
presented I really have nothing more to
add to that I think he's covered
everything very fully apart from to say
that when I was appointed after the
appeal my instruction was to try and
agree a scheme of reduction of the
height of the buildings to deal with as
much of the inspectors concerns as we
could and ultimately to try and agree a
scheme that in overall terms and on
balance was a better proposition than
that that originally been approved I
have discussed with the applicant just
as you're aware obviously their future
options should this be refused
um I've I've advised and I don't think
will take anything to appeal they will
if this is refused they will demolish
buildings and they will be rebuilt to
the approved scheme because they have no
other option but to do that
[Music]
um that's really all I have to say apart
from obviously with the conditions the
applicant would accept all of the
conditions that you would impose
um concerning the bond there is a bond
agreement with your suggest that's being
checked at the moment and I have
confirmed to Mr Pierce with a letter or
a statement of intent from the
applicants that they will abide by that
Bond and any conditions that should
permission be granted thank you members
thank you
are there any questions for the agent
councilor Barrett
thank you
um just a
wondering if you would agree also to if
you did get permission whether um you
would agree that baber could be
appointed as the building control we're
on an external uh
I think sorry I didn't turn that off
catched about it because there isn't
already an appointed building control
inspector which is a private inspector
I'm not sure how they would go around in
terminating that because they've already
inspected part of the buildings that are
built in terms of the foundations and
work that's already there I think it
might be quite difficult to transition
that from sort of back to the local
Authority I mean if that's something
that you felt would be desirable as I
can certainly have that conversation
thank you no chairman thank you I don't
want to the case officer might have a
comment as well but I would worry about
the lawfulness of the condition like
that to be honest and I would defer to
Mr Isabel then
chairman just uh just so you know I mean
understanding what
as to why Mark just said
uh we have as you can see from the
conditions uh and expectation to agree a
regime of inspection and in order to
give public confidence that we are
taking this every step of the way I
think it's important that we
will be seen to do that so the question
of the value of building control because
we can independently take our own advice
and building control as we go I think
we've probably achieved the same result
a bit without literally instructing our
own building control team to sign off on
the work so I'm confident that your
planning sense we've made a
recommendation that gives us an ongoing
close monitoring the situation which is
arguably what building control would
provide and we can take their advice as
needs be
okay sorry chair can I just interrupt
and add a little bit of extra over here
certainly Council Barrett you also had
the uh question for Mr wymark about the
drainage and would it be gravity or
would it need pumping but before we do
that it's something Mr Weimar said about
a draft being in circulation that is
certainly true
but the updated papers that you have
before you do add an extra layer of
security needed around the financial
contribution
the draft that was being circulated
earlier in the week doesn't go far
enough in our opinion in terms of Ace
what we understand to be a secure Bond
so I'm sure Mr y Mark and his client
will be looking at that issue but I just
wanted to be clear that if Mr Weymouth
was talking about the draft that was
circulated earlier in the week it
doesn't go far enough to give us the
comfort that the money would be there
when we needed it
but
but that's a matter that we will resolve
as we go forward should you be minded to
grow our planning permission
and the question of the drainage Mr Roy
Mark that's a good question about
drainage did you want it wasn't about
drone I was just just really following
on from that the issue about whether
should it be approved and you know
that's very much Up For Debate
um the conditions are quite complicated
and the site is very
um much in in public public mind
um and I think communication would be so
vital between a developer and building
neutral and the planning department but
I think it is is something I I would be
concerned about that sort of breaking
down in communication by a third party
being involved but if you've already got
your and presumably they they are very
aware of what's as being agreed and
proposed and and the conditions that are
going to be imposed should it be
get to that stage so I know
on this one but I'm I feel confident in
suggesting that
the Bailey and myself would be happy to
act as conduits
to translate transfer information to
Residents via Mr Weimar I'm conscious
that sensitivities are such that it
might not be welcome to have direct
approaches by developer but certainly
between us we would act as the the
go-betweens if that well we would do
that because that is naturally the
answer
please did you want to well yes just a
quick question I just wonder whether the
applicant would consider offering some
kind of compensation
um to the householders that have been
put out by this over the many years that
this has been going on I mean there's
considerable stress for the families
involved
um I just thought some kind of payment
to recognize that they have gone through
this would be would be welcome
absolutely entirely understand where
counselor Busby's coming from I must
regretfully advise that is not likely to
be a lawful development control
consideration today
doesn't mean they can't offer it
are you working on the principle if you
don't ask you don't go
thank you very much councilman
thank you chair Mr y Mark I'm about to
ask you the question I asked the
planning officer are you aware of any
people being impacted by the delay in
this development being completed
thank you
as far as I'm aware plots five and six
had no offers or sales that were
progressing at the time so no there's
nobody been impacted by that and if I
may just overlap that with what
councilor Busby just said I appreciate
where the comments came from and I will
ask the question that of the applicants
and just see what response I get and
that's all I can do
yeah
that's the question it really follows on
from councilor Busby
and partly you've asked for that but
um slide 64 and 65 shows the garage
next door which their inspection pit
floods now I understand that we can't
say it's caused by this development but
I think we're all grown up to know that
the more concrete you lay down and the
water's got to run down that slope
is there any way that the applicant
would tour to the garage people and see
whether they can help solve this problem
because if it's not water tight which I
think is what the officer said he
thought it wasn't water type and whether
that could be a shared expense or
something I I just feel that to say it's
not our responsibility which I suppose
it isn't but if you weren't being
flooded and you now are because of a
development site
um you're going to want somebody to
blame you you've asked your question
thank you I think
that's why I might reply
okay thank you Council to be it
um Mr Pearson I did inspect on Friday
and did talk to Mr Oxford and we did
obviously look to the pit and discussed
it
um it's fairly obvious on site where
water is running down the drive it's
washing away the loose area it's not
really flown down the concrete and there
is a water bar at the doors Mr Oxford
did accept that it wasn't surface water
was running in the concert he expressed
to me was that with the groundworks in
building the houses basically because
they have piled foundations he wondered
whether that had altered hydrology where
the water table would have come up I
have discussed that informally with the
civil engineers they said you get that
quite a lot if they're basement
excavations near properties but they
thought it very unlikely in this
situation and felt it more likely to be
just natural groundwater but I
appreciate the comment and again as with
the the neighbors I will put that to the
applicants to see whether they will
consider something
um just following on from what Mr Pierce
has said that the driveway will be
resurfaced probably in tarmac and what
we can do we can address the levels
there possibly with a sort of slightly
raised curving on the garage side so
that water is directed away rather than
towards their doorway
the chief Fanning officer has a comment
to make about
thank you Jim it's not related to that
but to councilor Barrett's query
regarding inspection and I think there's
an important point about confidence and
just looking at the third condition
we've recommended that talks about an
inspection protocol and I'm going to
suggest a change to the wording of that
to include
effectively it refers only to roof Works
in in the text that you have in the
paper circulated today but I think it
should be alteration levels and warning
Works to allow for measuring for
compliance and compliance checking by
the local planning Authority but I'm
going to add a sentence to the
recommendation with your agreement
chairman which is and the protocol
should include measures for giving
concurrent notice to the parish council
in the interests of transparency so that
we are all going eyes open from here
thank you Jim I'm happy with that
okay okay we can deal with that when we
come to the the last sign
are there any more questions for the
agent
no I came to that I was going to we were
going to revisit whether the pump was
needed
um
on the
Hydra break
yes the drainage that's installed at the
moment all of the surface water drainage
which is from the roofs of the buildings
and the road gullies all goes to the
attenuation tank and that's all gravity
fed
there's no pump required for that should
this application be refused and the bill
was demolished in the ground reduced and
the buildings rebuilt their sort of
approved level it is possible that we
may need to install pumps on foul and
service water just to pump them up to
the drains that are already installed on
site but that's the only requirement
there would be for a pump
okay thank you very much
we're now moving to debate
would someone like to kick off Peter
you've been first or Melanie you're the
ward member you you would you like to
open you don't have to
thank you that's fine
um thank you for asking me
um
well as we all know this application
predates
um some of this as counselors some of us
are on as committee members
um
and
it's you know the benefit of hindsight
is wonderful why was it approved you
might say well it's got so many sort of
issues with it
did it did it get that full examination
and that scrutiny at earlier stages but
there does seem to have been a lot a lot
to to look at what those flaws were and
and to try and try and work through them
um
I I'm a little bit concerned about
different aspects of it
um uh the Heritage you know it's not
just the proximity to White Horse house
um it's it's the proximity to other
other neighbors
um that that are also of a Heritage
value and the conservation area
um
but
um you know there's I'd like to hear
what other counselors do or what their
thoughts are
um and that's always useful to bring out
any other points in the debate so I will
hopefully hear what my fellow councils
have to
think about it
Pastor Jameson please
no thank you share well I do worry
um that if we approve this application
it may be seen by a residents
particularly not just the viewers but of
everywhere but we effectively reward in
um applicants who go against approved
plans I mean
or not holding them to account
so anyway I don't think that my tasks
look bad but then having said that if we
don't the applicant has already said
they're going to build what's already
been approved which I think is a worse
scenario for the residents in the
current proposal so it's a bit tall at
the moment
on um my way to go here
okay
and thank you Mr chairman
um this is a very difficult one and I've
read through the papers
um I've made quite a lot of comments
down here a lot of the questions have
been answered so I won't go through that
again
um but
I I still am concerned I think I do
share councilor Jameson's comments that
it perhaps sends out the wrong message
um
and I think perhaps deep down most
likely what is being proposed could be
an improvement but
you know I heard from the parish council
and um the she speaks on behalf of the
residents and what have you
if I lived there
what would I think
I wouldn't like it
I wouldn't want it in my back Garden
like that
but if I insisted on a refusal it could
mean that they end up with the original
planning permissions and that may not be
as good as what's in front of us today
so I am finding it very difficult but
I think I'm balanced I'm going to come
down on the side of the residence on
this one and I think we should send the
message out and that we should
perhaps
take a different direction to what the
officers suggesting but I'm going to
listen to what my fellow members have to
say before I actually make my mind up
thank you thank you both really
yeah there's there's kind of some
satisfaction in sending a message but
at the end of the day it appears as
though
the house is going to be either shrunk
to the size or knocked down and rebuilt
to the size
the vet who got to ask yourself if
you're a neighbor do you want all that
extra time and mess from demolishing the
whole house and then starting from
scratch clearing out the Earth to bring
the levels down and then rebuilding it
or would you prefer them to just lower
the roof and get on with it and get out
of get off the site
for me this has been going on far too
long if I lived there I think I just
want them to get out
and it therefore seems that they're
going to end up with a house behind them
you either have another 18 months of
construction work and demolition work
behind you going on or you let them get
on with it and get out within say three
months so I think we should support the
officer's recommendation on this one
anyone else want to make a comment
councilor Hinton
yeah I I've got sympathy with the parish
council I've got sympathy with cancer
beer and cancer Jameson
I've got sympathy with
councilor Busby's position as well
in the round I think perhaps
councilor Busby's position is Bobby
ultimately better form of residence
especially as we're looking at a maximum
of 30 weeks
of expert disturbance whereas if they
knock down and start again it could be
another year or so of disturbance
the original decision
wasn't a good one
I know that there are several instances
in my own village where decisions have
been made some by delegated decisions
done by this committee which
are not very good decisions are going to
cause major problems
so planning has always been a
controversial subject
we've tried to strike the right route
falling as much as we can within the
policies that we as a council have
agreed and which are off sometimes
dictated To Us by central government
so it's a it's a complicated situation
but I think I I would tend to agree with
the councilor buzzfeed's final
assessment that ultimately I think that
the officer's recommendation is going to
be the better one for
the the local residents in terms of it
gets the first and bother over and done
with as quickly as possible and in a
slightly more acceptable way than is
potentially there if they knock down and
reveal
thank you Council councilman
sure
yes I I have great sympathy with the uh
the parish and the parish council
um but for me I think I would rather a
resolution be under the supervision of
our planners so there's more control
over it rather than just allowing it the
developers to go ahead and develop as
originally was planned thank you
thank you Council McLaren
anyone else come to a hospital
yes thank you Mr chairman first of all
that as I've already alluded to the the
site visits with with Simon Bailey and
other officers I think uh proved and
proved provided the many issues that
were on this site
obviously having a sympathy with what
councilor beer said it is a difficult
decision but as it stands with the um
and I must give pay tribute to the
parish council for their long
work on and residents on the the work
that They carried out to to get this uh
sorted out with with our planning
offices
um but as I say I have great sympathy
with with all of that both for and
against and I agree with councilor Busby
and Clarence McLaren that the issues
will be on whether they want to have all
that disruption going on for another
possibly a year and a half or so when
they're only going to get what they had
on the original applications
so
I would favor the the lesser of the
evils and have possibly as uh as our
excellent
presentation by by
our office of Vincent the uh the Water
problems that are there which would be
um
providing a a sensible conclusion to the
drainage system so
I I feel I feel for for everybody in
this but the the better or the
alternative that our officers have come
up with I think is is the best
opportunity of getting this long
long-standing issue resolved and
hopefully when covid is finished we all
get back to together again thank you
thank you Mr chairman thank you sir
anyone else
make my own comments that I feel we need
to come to a resolution with this for
the sake of everyone concerned with
great sympathy for everyone but I think
that's my position
Philip the chief Bank officer you wanted
to make a comment thank you chairman yes
I think it's important that I just just
pick up that point around timing that
Council the buzz being counseling and
others have mentioned
one has to bear in mind that if we take
the position of enforcing the
enforcement notice and requiring
demolition
then there is no timetable attached to
that planning permission for the
completion of those Works to draw a line
under this
so we have within the recommendation
before you
what you might describe as an exit
strategy albeit it does not happen in
August it happens within a 30-week build
timetable
if you proceed to refuse the application
if you proceed then to require the
demolition of the building the Planning
Commission does not go away it can be
exercised over time and within an
uncertain period of which the council
has no control
um to get back to councilor Beer's
question what would I want if I lived
there
if it were me personally I would want
the certainty of timetable I might not
like this but that's what I would prefer
and
I think that's as much as I can say
thank you chair may I add one small
point with your blessing
it's the point you made councilor beer
about deterrence
and I think what we've got to
think about is were you minding the
ground planning permission what you will
see as a result
is both roofs being removed
a large part of the first floor being
smashed down
Windows taken out you will see extensive
demolition
and I think the message to any developer
out there would be I if you are going to
abuse the planning system you will be
expected to remedy it and we will be
taking enforcement and I think it does
send a strong message to see parts of
buildings being smashed down
in order to deliver a solution so whilst
it may not be full demolition I'd be
very surprised if the Press weren't out
there taking pictures of buildings being
smashed
down
and that to me sends a very strong
message to the development industries
that we're not a soft touch that would
be my professional opinion
okay any other comments
if not I'm looking for a poke sorry I'm
sorry
you're totally the wrong place thank you
chair
um just uh it's probably worth just
worth pointing out and following on from
Vincent's comments and um from uh Philip
comments as well that enforcement action
is not intended to be punitive it's not
intended to be a punishment the the
point of enforcement action is to to get
to a solution and I think the comments
that I've put forward for Vincent's
committee report that overall
um the the proposal was put forward
through the negotiations that Vincent
and I have undertaken with Mr wymark
seek to resolve pretty much all the
issues that were raised in the
enforcement notice and dealt with at the
injunct at the inquiry late last year
the only issue obviously that hasn't
been
fully resolved is the positioning of
block five that's very difficult without
actually demolishing the building but
what we've what we've tried to achieve
with Mr vimark through the application
is to ameliorate the harm from that
proximity issue as best we possibly can
so overall this application is is
sufficient to overcome the reasons for
serving the enforcement notice therefore
it's a resolution to the enforcement
notice and therefore it achieves the aim
of the enforcement notice
thank you chair thank you for coming
okay Council that's where you have a
commercial bank or you want to make a
proposition ah
I in that case
cancer Baron
okay thank you so busy please yeah I
propose that we accept the officer's
recommendations or with the latest
whatever the Amendments that we've
received and also
um with the condition that the the wall
is waterproofed the New Garden Wall is
waterproofed
do we have a second then
answer is you say anything
I second the most
your your condition of waterproofing the
wall did the officers pick that up
chairman before Vince corrects me on
this we have
um the fourth obligation is about a
commitment to repair and place the
garden walls
uh can I suggest that's the sort of
place we put this rather than write
another condition in so arguably we'd
make that uh to include measures to
ensure it's waterproof
to waterproof it
to a satisfactory manner which we can
agree in the standard okay and you had
another sentence that and and I wanted
to change the wording of con condition
three recommended to you submission of
any inspection protocol requiring that
Council has 10 working days prior
written notice of the start of and then
I was going to alter that to say rather
than roof Works alteration uh to levels
and Walling alterations roof level and
Walling Works to allow for measures for
compliance and compliance checking by
the local planning Authority and then a
new sentence protocol shall include
measures for the giving of concurrent
notice to the parish council in the
interests of transparency
there
thank you
Ryan we have
any more comments or should we go to a
vote Council Bank may I just make a
comment yes as the board member of
course it's only right and transparent I
thought members of my Parish Council
here present so
um
I know the
the views expressed by the chair and the
The Village utterly well members of a
lot of villagers are utterly opposed to
this and I can understand the anger and
frustration that they felt at Living
this it's like a an open sore really
um
but we've listened to to different views
with and it's just not as I don't think
it's just as simple as as um as a
refusal and and insisting on on
demolition because the that also has an
adverse impact on people's lives
um and so I have you know come to to a
um a conclusion about about this that
that I will be supporting the the
proposal to to approve um with with some
reluctance
um it's not ideal but it's just not as
simple as as as refusal and everything's
fine after that
thank you
in that case can I ask the chief coming
up to read I think exactly what the
resolution is
the time chairman the recommendation is
as circulated to you and tabled today in
the updated recommendation table 14th of
July I will not read that out those
papers or whether you and Vincent has
shown them on the screen we are amending
obligation for the commitment to repair
straight replace the garden walls which
shall be waterproof to an appropriate
standard between white horse house Etc
and then the text that you have already
there and then in the conditions beneath
that condition three submission of an
inspection protocol requiring that the
council has 10 working days prior
written notice at the start of uh roof
alteration uh levels and Walling Works
to allow for measuring compliance and
compliance checking by the local
planning Authority full stop the
protocol which shall include measures
shall include measures for the giving of
concurrent notice to the parish council
in the interests of transparency thank
you thank you if that's the case can I
ask the government's office declare to
conduct the vote thank you yeah
members your vote has been updated and
is now in progress
sure
would you like me to take your vote
verbally I think you're going to have to
okay just kick me out
um I'm four well thank you
would you like me to take your vote the
oblique helps Laura spawn
to updating okay there's no problem I
can tell you about everything so yeah
I'm full thank you
foreign
that's nine votes for one against and
obviously councilor Park is no longer in
the chamber
so that is carried thank you very much
that's carried and I'd like to thank you
all
for your attendance on that one
thank you members of the public
I propose that we now have a break of 15
minutes to allow you to change around
the audiences and and
Dave to have a cup of coffee and the
rest of us too
have a comfort right
foreign
thank you good afternoon
thank you for coming back
we will now move on to the next planning
application which is
dc2102319 land to the east of Station
Road along Melford Suffolk
Catherine would you like to do your
presentation please
thank you chair and good morning members
um this is an application Reserve
matters for 150 dwellings in Long
Melford the outlines of a principal and
the access has already previously been
approved
um and so this just focuses on all of
our aspects the layout scale appearance
and the public open space and other
Landscaping
as part of this application the
applicant has also requested to
discharge a number of conditions I'll
discuss those briefly at the end of this
presentation
so the previous outline permission the
the history that you may or may not be
aware of it was taken to appeal for fail
to determine our recommendation would
have been refusal it got called in by
the Secretary of State who subsequently
looked at it and approved the appeal
which is why we are where we are today
there was a section 106 that was agreed
with the the outline permission which
secured also the affordable housing it
secured land for early years as well as
a contribution for the early years
provision footpath contribution as well
as securing the transfer of the open
space and suds to a management company
so that's already been secured by
section 106 which has agreed with the
outline
Village
this is the site flashing in red Station
Road is obviously to the West as you can
see
so just to put it into context as to
where it is
this is a wider aerial review so you can
see the the built form is predominantly
to the north and to a Southwest
so there are a few constraints near the
site
um so you've got listed a few listed
buildings and within long Melford tpos
and public footpaths now there's a
public footpath that runs across the the
front of a site and also through the
middle up through the front section
sorry so it's public footprot across
here and also along here
there's also a single conservation up to
the north and special landscape over
here but as you can see it doesn't fall
within that site
flood zones
and this action here is a local nature
reserve it it sits I'd recently to your
site
so this is just a point for the access
which has already been agreed
and then also you want to discuss the
reserved matters
so in terms of parking
um the the parking can appear slightly
confusing in terms of it looks like
there is triple parking in places
however I just want to point out to
members that actually the the garages
that are proposed on these plots are
excess to requirements so the three bed
plots which feature along this Main Road
only require from Suffolk parking
guidance 2019 adopter standards only
require two spaces they've all got two
spaces plus a garage so they've got
Surplus parking requirements so whilst
it looks like it's triple it isn't for
that purpose the four bedroom units
require free spaces and in those
instances there's a garage two spaces in
France so you've got here two garage
spaces in front and then another space
opposite
so there isn't actually in the scheme
any any triple parking the garages
aren't considered as an allocated space
for the park and provision as such
um obviously there is sometimes
concerned that if there is an ample
parking on site people will park on the
green grass areas or open spaces so blow
um have a sea thought carefully about
this and there's a Timber knee rail
fence around most of the site so to
secure the green open space as well as
various planting so cars can't park on
any of the open space areas
in terms of a layout and scale
the layout follows a main road through
the site due to Topography of the site
and obviously where the locations of the
open space and attenuation basins give
them a nature reserve the layout does
have more of a linear form around the
center with private streets and
driveways towards the outer edges here
you can see at the start of the site the
provision for the early years site
business has been agreed with Suffolk
County Council and they're content with
this
just shows the main road
because you'll see free recite and
you've got a smaller road which should
also be adopted and then you've got the
private roads along here and the outer
edges of the Green Space
here you've got Central Focus focal
points with raised table tops as well
and shared areas
so in terms of the layout and the
townscape
the all of the dwellings look out onto
open space and provide surveilled area
for any of the walkways and with green
space and surroundings it also means
from a Countryside point of view and
from the footpaths you're not looking
onto fences you have the open space
followed by front elevations
here you've got Vista points within the
the sort of middle sections again
they're all the Outlook demonstrates
that replaces are surveyed and there's
always a feature to to look at and as
you'll see later and also within the
plans obviously each each property
there's a focal point and a feature
there's no blank elevations or any of
these properties look out onto
let me just show you the different
Aussie Vista points
this is a top section of cycle so I
couldn't fit it all run clearly
though in terms of the affordable
housing
it's pepper potted around the site so
you've got affordable rented a few
around here a couple up here
and the shared ownership a few down here
a few up here again this will see only
one half of a site
and the same along here
there are a number of single story
properties with Bungalows equate to
about 9.3 percent of the housing
provided so you can see obviously the
the lighter yellow is the single stories
and then the orange over two stories
shows or see where they're spread out
within the massage
[Music]
so in terms of the the layout and the
design there are three main character
areas within the scheme you've got the
the green Edge well you can see
identified along the outside
um which leads into the footpaths
attenuation basins open space and play
area we're a free focal squares and the
the character area my buildings and the
dwellings within those um most squares
all have their own ident unique
identified viable character as well as
the streets again
um the houses within each of the street
sections are all um all have certain
materials so that they end up being free
clear distinctive areas of development
which together blend into good quality
design and create a a nice Street Scene
I haven't included all of the house
types in here because I'm sure you can
appreciate there are quite a few so
these are the Bungalows to be proposed
you can see there's features such as bay
windows
more house types as you can see there's
different features on on you know each
of the house types different elevations
different Ridge Heights and roof pitches
so these are just a slide sort of a
street scene
so this is as you come into site so site
entrance is here
in the early site earlier site would be
here and then you come in and this is
you know this is the first Street Scene
visual aspect you'll see on the site
this street scene is of part of a main
road
so this will be part of the sort of the
blue Air on my previous slides
this is looking out onto the green open
space
and towards the east end of the site so
here you can see that there's a mixture
of design there's no close-boarded
fencing it's all with with garages in
between
this is just streets in a third cluster
of Bungalows just a section
and again this is another Corner edge of
the site where you've got the open space
and the footpaths that are run I thought
to it along the north outside of a site
but if you were able to look back Mrs
roughly what you'd be able to obviously
see on the site
this is just another plan of a parking
so the example parking the example
visitor spaces Suffolk County Council
and highways are happy with the proposed
scheme and the parking Provisions made
and this is just some visual
representations of what the site will
look like
so the site entrance would be from here
and you come into a site here in the
countryside and and further fields are
over here and you've got the two large
attenuation basins here
and the nature reserve and the footpath
runs along here
the video shows the the amount of green
space and open space areas that have
been provided in comparison to see the
built form
and again this is just from a different
Viewpoint that there is a green belt all
along the site
um we're quite dense parking uh planting
sorry
in terms of boundary detail this just
demonstrates that there also are
post-boarded fences in in various places
but there's the new rail fence on the
open Countryside and like on the open
space
there's a landscaping plan as you can
see that the site is heavily landscaped
with a mixture of planting hedgerows
Wildflower Meadows and species the Play
service landscape as well as the
ecologists are now content with what's
being proposed
thank you
so the site entrance is obviously here
here is Station Road
[Music]
um
you can also see that the site entrance
opens up as an attenuation base which
would be on your left and a sort of
grass grassy area Meadowland the
footpath
kind of runs across here the public
footpath around across here so that's
not being touched there will also be an
opening in the Hedge so that as people
come into the site rather than I'll see
you walking past the the open space at
the front and then heading on to the
footpath they can cut through there will
be a a cut in like lawn path
so on this previous slide this this
yellow aspect on site clearance a spigot
mortar base was found
and so law have decided rather than
obviously trying to get rid of it or
hide it or anything they're going to
make it into like in a sort of visually
um open space area so retaining it as
part of our site
um MRC this is the spigot mortar in
question this is obviously what it used
to look like and you used in the war
um so it's got quite a lot of history
behind it and the idea is that they're
going to incorporate it into a site with
a bench planting seated area and there
was discussions of potentially having a
board of some sort of visitors board to
explain the history of it in as to why
it's there for people that don't
necessarily
understand what it is
so that's obviously the reserved matters
part in terms of conditions
um usually the conditions come in and
the planning officer has delegated
authority to determine those but because
this is part of the reserve matters
application they are then before members
so there are a number of conditions
which we're looking to approve and sign
off today condition 5 11 16 21 22 and 24
they've all been before the um our
statue consultees and none of them have
raised any objections so therefore we're
recommending that they be discharged in
full
in terms of conditions 7 9 10 and 13. at
the moment the statutory console T still
have a few issues or concerns with the
information submitted and therefore
additional information or amendments are
needed since creating this PowerPoint
and also since the committee report
before members uh updated construction
management plan has been submitted and
is now being looked at and consulted by
environmental health so hopefully we can
be in a position to discharge Road
shortly but recommendation for this
these outstanding conditions to be
discharge is for it to be delegated to
or see officer
so the recommendation is approval with
conditions set out in the committee
report and then in terms of the
conditions recommended approval of
conditions 5 11 16 21 22 and 24 and then
delegation Powers Chief planning officer
for 7 9 10 and 13 on submission of
further details without a satisfactory
thank you Catherine
are there any questions for the officer
John John Hinton
I've got several actually uh for the
officer um
can I ask you to speak up and apparently
somebody talking thank you
for talking about do we just been
talking about conditions I noticed on uh
page 97 of the report
Suffolk County Council flood and Water
Management comments received
and for the reserve matters application
a refusal of this to discharge
conditions 11 and 16. but you're
proposing that they should be approved
and I suppose connected to that it talks
about
um local drainage board approval uh
internal drainage board approval well
who is that because I don't think there
is one for this part of the world
um okay
um sleds should be an updated response
in the report pack um apologies if it's
not but floods have now confirmed that
they're happy with the two outstanding
conditions and their 11 and 16 can be
discharged hence the recommendation
um
not sure if you give me a couple minutes
I can find out exactly when we received
the comments from floods to just confirm
the date
and as to the local drainage board the
um we did consult I think it was East
Suffolk boss it's outside their their
remit so that was why that was
dealt with
John sorry we can't
so well outside the Eastern
Regional whatever it is drainage board
because it doesn't cover them but surely
if it doesn't they don't cover it while
somebody else must cover it
or do we just abandon that part of along
Wellford
sorry I'm just trying to find it and
Report what page did you say it was on
I mentioned on 97
there's another mentioned further on but
somewhere else that talks about the East
Eastern drainage board saying nothing to
do with us gov but then a bit later on
it mentions them again
along with the rather strange notation
note to be added to say no materials to
be stored within eight of any
Watercourse or water body whatever that
means
I think it's a typo some description but
he's repeated several times so it's a
obviously been a cut and paste
on condition 11 as well
the flood Authority replied on the 29th
of June
would be condition s be flood Authority
replied on the 23rd of June and said
that
the conditions for 11 and 16 would be
satisfactory
so what about attacking your report can
you tell us
foreign
every time I try and search it just
gives me the
um
okay my moments that's a problem for
some reason should we park that one for
a moment and and move on to some other
questions and we'll come back
I
I thought you might have
um but I think is the relevancy of your
first question I think we've actually
let somebody else have a go and then
we'll come back when because they're all
possibly related we're doing that button
contradicting Danger
beer would you go to be would you like
to ask topic questions
a couple of questions
um for clarification
and Parkin and you touched on that very
lightly that's up for discussion today
can you point them out to us on the
screen because I think they were blue or
yellow but I couldn't see them from here
I need you to sell them out
um and some of them didn't have any
parking spaces
um garage
space so they've just got parking spaces
is that correct
I'm sick sorry and I'd like to know how
many on the whole site because as we
know
um that there won't be enough parking
spaces despite despite what is said in
the papers uh because people have two or
three cars don't they so we're going to
end up with them parking all over the
place and I think you said
um
well it says on page 99
five lines on comments on Parkin and the
last bullet pipes are house types
without garages Garden sheds
um sorry no the one before that the
developer had provided a traditional
parking spaces the dwellings on private
drones given sufficient Park and
um now is this on the service strips
that you refer to which run along the
edges of the proposed roadways
so in terms of the park
there is
330 parking spaces 38 visitor spaces and
75 garage spaces
um in terms of what you've just
mentioned on page 99 there is a note at
the bottom it perhaps isn't clear that
they've now been resolved these parking
issues so where there were four bedroom
houses considered a triple parking
um this has now been altered so that
there isn't any triple parking other
than where there's a garage so there
will be two car parking spaces then a
garage but then the third parking space
that is required for a four bed property
is either opposite or behind in certain
locations the agent and also the
applicant are here today and I think
they when they have their chance to
discuss or talk they will talk about
parking sorry the point about the shared
surface Road maintained a strip of one
liter wide for
um this is what I think is grassed
strips along the edge of the carriageway
where the services
and the estate roads are a
Sam Harvey has asked for those to be
dealt with by condition so as towards
the end of the paper in my conclusion
and recommendation for conditions it
does recommend that details will be a
state road and the footpaths are
provided
another you've missed the point I'm
sorry my question to you is
on that are are we heavened the shared
surface rose out of a maintenance strip
one meter wide each side of the
carriageway which allows the hallway to
be maintained in the erection Street
line if these strips are to be
considered for utility service plants
the strips need to be to me now is that
going to be a grass area because we've
had this on other Estates particularly
in great corner now knowing glemsford I
believe they've had some where they have
this garage grass Birds run along the
edge of the carriageway
and people park there two wheels of
their car on these because there's
nowhere else to pass after a little
while they get all churned up and mugged
and they become an absolute mess they
should be tarmac rather than grass
and if you want to see any of these come
to great cornard and they'll show you
meters of it okay in case a bit I think
the the age would be willing to talk
to this
yeah well we've brought these strips up
Mr chairman as you know okay they are a
problem and if we have opposed them hey
I want to be clear that this is what
we're proposing it may not be what
they're going to do
what do you understand the strips to be
of you're also oh man
um I'm not entirely sure
um I think they were meant to be grasped
but b along the adopted roads
um and then you've got the private
driveways towards the end of the open
space and that's where you've got the um
rail fencing or the hedgerows to ensure
see there's no encroachment onto those
areas of open space I appreciate your
saying in the middle of a shared access
areas but hopefully the agent can
clarify exactly what they're proposing
there
thank you
have you had any luck resolving
councilor Henson's question
because she's got about six more
or five more sorry
yes cancer bone you like to ask your
question
thank you did you just mention shared
surface roads did I hear correctly and
can you describe what what that is
where it is
the the share surface Rose of the
tabletop areas on the on my site and
also also be adopted areas it's only the
private Jai drives towards the outer
edges of a site
um that won't have a different well
they'll have a different surface towards
the main area
is what is the surface
you know black squares
right and is that block hit like a
brickwork yeah it'll be it's likely to
be blocked paviors
okay I mean what is the plan then for
the weeds control in that sort of area
because you always get weeds protruding
um
I don't know of anything other than the
fact that there's some highways would
highways are adopting those areas of the
road
um so presumably that would be part of a
section 38 when highways come to adopt
it
cancers
thank you chair
um I'm just wondering there's a quite a
bit of debate about the size of garages
because people seem to have larger cars
so that's one question about the size of
the garages and
um may I have a second one
um and I don't think it's the parish
council
um but I was a bit concerned about the
exit onto the main Station Road we I
know that road very well and it seems
highways don't think it's a problem
thank you
so in terms of the main access onto the
road access was already
I say agreed it was part of the outline
permission that the Secretary of State
allowed and has been part of obviously a
number of conditions onto the outline as
well as section 106 and highways have no
objection to it so that's already been
agreed
um so in terms of the application today
that's that's not for consideration that
access it would be obviously the
highways within from the site of state
roads and parking
um for that one in terms of the size of
their edges they're all up to Suffolk
parking guidelines about I think the the
point here is that the garages are more
there to provide cycle storage and
spaces and that hence the additional
parking spaces elsewhere
um to the site so people also have
bigger cars they should meet the
requirements and the guidelines
um
they shouldn't very fit but there is
alternative parking for them along the
site
if we go back to council Hinton I think
the painting officer Marcus is found an
answer to your your question right yeah
thank you chair can you all hear me
I'll take that as a yes um so I think
the the approval from floods came in
about the time the report was published
so there may have been something missing
from the things you have in front of you
but I've got it before me an email from
the floods team on 29th of June
um where
where it is said that the floods
Authority
agrees to the discharge of conditions 11
and 16. and that references the thing
that they're asked for which was
something about the Overland flow
exceedance route
that has been submitted and on that
basis the local lead flood Authority
does not object to the discharge of
condition 16.
but who is the flood Authority
the local lead flood Authority tends to
be the county so in this case it's um
it's Jason skilled in the Suffolk County
Council
so the internal drainage board is not
relevant
internal drainage boards not relevant so
I can't hear you counselor the internal
drainage board who has set
why are they there if Suffolk County
Council are responsible for their
operations
all I can tell you is that the statue
consultee has agreed to the discharge of
the um condition
you've seen something somewhere where
they've referred to the internal
drainage board and that's that's led to
some confusion is that fair point let me
beware in the background and get back to
you that if I may counselor
we really need to
know the wonders of Technology
um yeah let's move on from that page
anyway top of page 99 it talks about uh
combined cycling and pedestrian ways but
it doesn't talk about them getting any
bigger than the two meters that's
required for pedestrian ways so Cycles
are going what float in the middle of
the air or are they going to run the
pedestrians over normally we like to see
those bigger and certainly when we
talked about the site at um Chilton
Woods we made the the paths that much
wider to a coat with both cycles and
pedestrians
so the opposite second comment or so I
believe that a matter to basically be
conditioned as part of Suffolk County
Council highways response they wanted to
condition the footpaths and cycleway
provision
in terms of the width of it that can be
dealt with that we expect a certain
width but the wording that Suffolk
County Council have used in there says
that they should be increased to two
meters well two meters isn't wide enough
for pedestrians and Cycles
that was because the original wits was
they were talking about one meter
if that's so we're still not wide enough
if that's what Suffolk County Council
highways are recommending or asking as a
requirement as a statute we can ask for
or see wider and
um you know hopefully the the developers
would be willing to provide that but as
a as a necessity they need to be
meeting Suffolk County Council highways
requirements
next question
um I've assumed in the background
information on strategic housing that
the
Ipswich Housing market area strategic
housing market assessment document
updated in 2019 is no longer relevant
because of course everything has been
changed in 2020 to go with our local
plan and any problems that were in the
2019 have just disappeared
if you look at the Strategic
the infrastructure delivery plan that's
what will happen there but but what I'm
talking about here is that have we got
any more accurate
housing needs than
2014's Suffolk housing needs survey
because people keep talking about homes
for life
which means that they will cope with
being older persons homes as well as
young people at homes but we never see
any mention of it anywhere in the in the
housing requirements we just end up with
over 50 percent of the houses being 40
being four bedroom
the the comments you're returning to you
are from obviously strategic housing so
they're they're the clients they've
provided that's the data they're using
and they
um documents and guidance that they're
going off of and so it's their their
comments I can't obviously speak on
their behalf I believe the data is being
updated but at the moment that is what
we've got but it's with the policy team
and obviously strategic housing that is
purely their response so they're using
the 2014 data
so the work the wording at the top of
page 100 about the preferred mix of open
market homes where it talked about older
people's Express their desire for Chalet
Bungalows of one and a half story
um it just ignored
in terms of what the developers are
going to provide
you can't be insist on something being
put in
the the developers providing Bungalows
and initially obviously then they're not
one and a half story though single story
Bungalows but they are um providing
those on site
um
even this is reserve matters I don't
think we condition or or you know ask
for them to be a story and a half and
also it's noted that the affordable
housing and housing mix had been agreed
by the section 106 and this is their
preference but as you'll go to see I
think it must be I don't think their
comments extend past the page 100 oh
yeah they do they don't have any issue
with the schemas proposed and therefore
we we didn't see it fit to ourselves you
know one and a half story bungalows
thank you
uh I'm looking at the um developers
applicants energy statement and just
wanted to clarify that the developer
were planning to put in fossil fuel
boilers in the house that's question one
and this further took care of councilor
hinton's point
at the moment there's no dedicated
cycleways on the development at all is
that correct
there's no dedicated cycleways as such
and it was like a trim Trail around the
site I'll see the footpath and so on
um but the the footpath would be
provided to be wide enough for both you
know what pedestrians and cyclists as
per condition from highways
um in terms of the boilers it will be
Combi boilers at the moment there isn't
a requirement to get rid of gas boilers
um and we have no policies in place for
that
um they are providing solar panels on my
site towards the on the roofs of the
properties in the northeast corner to
meet the 10 in terms of renewable
energies that they are required at the
moment to provide
um and that also goes to I think one of
the conditions I can't remember off the
top of my head but that's the
sustainability condition that's been
signed off and that our sustainability
team are content with with that
okay thanks a beer thank you Mr cup me
off I don't ask one question I heard
through but anyway
um my second one is uh I'm I think a
slide 35 if you can get it up it shows
through
um sort of hammerheads roads that go
through up to where the
um we've created a boundary line across
the field
um is there any reason why we got three
sort of roads going up and stopping at a
dead end just like that
yes
these as a Hammerheads is that what you
mean that they're just going up to a
dead end right yeah but so that they
they could potentially break through and
come into those fields at different
places
the the reason for for these roads is
then to access ocb's dwellings so this
is a private driveway off here
well you're saying they'll never be used
as an access onto that field
I mean I I can't comment this to I can't
comment as to what what will happen
that's an unfair question for you okay I
accept is an unfair question but I mean
um really we're creating a boundary
fence along there
um and we've got these roads going up we
all know what's going to happen there a
slow 39
um it shows it shows overhead cables
wires surely they should be Underground
can't we get them put underground and a
new development
that they're all doing it sorry in
existence which is is why they're there
they're inexistence yeah well can't we
try and talk to them and see if they can
get them put underground I mean just
because they're already there can't we
try and see if we can get them put
underground do we have a look at the
picture slowly you see what I mean
they are they're horrible
look at that
I mean I think that's the main splines
along Milford a little bit careful well
whatever they are it's ugly
um it's um yes but I that's overhead
cables are ugly wherever
um and and I don't think we can confirm
this that this way within the agent's
control
well I'll ask the agents we'll ask the
agents when we get to that point yeah
okay thank you Mr chairman
no thanks sir I've got more on the uh
the drainage issue I'm just going to
clarify
um Council into referred to
an independent drainage board I think
that it's using to change with the term
internal drainage board I think that
might be what we're discussing here I've
done a bit of research for your
information and it's every day's a
school day and internal drainage board
is a type of operating Authority which
is established in areas of special
drainage needs in English in England and
Wales
so in this case we consulted and if you
turn to page 85 of your agendas under
National consultees we consult the East
Suffolk Inland drainage board and also
these Suffolk um actually sorry twice if
we can consult them and they advise is
outside the internal drainage District
of East Suffolk so therefore it's not
it's not um susceptible to that sort of
consideration
Council Hinton if that helps
so what we're basically saying is that
the use of an internal damage board in
that paragraph on page 97 was erroneous
in that it should have been Suffolk
County Council
that's what it looks like to me
yesterday
thank you thanks for Far Cry
yeah and I don't want to labor that
point but um I was just doing some
research on the East Africa drainage
board and it is confusing for planning
connections why are we using apparently
they're a national consult here
according to page 85 so I'm just curious
to know why we're using a national
consultee that that has no interest in
the area in which it has been consulted
so I mean I don't want to labor the
point but um just it's very confusing um
probably it's just one of those whereas
maybe near to let's check let's be sure
I would guess that may have been the
reason perhaps the mapping was
inaccurate and that's how it happened
but the result is they have no
objections
no more okay Catherine thank you very
much indeed
moving on
we generally representative from the
parish or an objective
or a supporter but we do have the age of
presence
James Bailey
thank you sir
you have three minutes to address the
the panel and I'm relatively sure you
may be having some questions afterwards
thank you
here we go can everybody hear me
thank you very much good afternoon chair
members my name is James Bailey and I'm
the planning consultant that has been
assisting blow homes with their
application at Station Road Long Melford
I'm joined today by Steve Lee from blore
homes and between us we should be able
to answer the questions that you have
we're here to discuss a site that maybe
District Council are very familiar with
and needs little introduction the
history of this site includes the
previous outline application in 2018 the
subsequent appeal in 2019 and then the
ruling from the Secretary of State in
2020. despite its previous history and
the contentiousness associated with the
site blore homes is a national house
Builder has sought to actively bring
forward a scheme for the land in a
positive and Progressive Way Through The
Reserve matters application that is
before you today they've engaged in
lengthy pre-application discussions with
both the district and County Council
officers in order to address fundamental
issues with the site such as highways
and drainage or have also tackled issues
of design and layout head on focal
points have been created the materials
have been discussed changed and agreed
there have been improved location for
the proposed Bungalows and certain
properties will now act as a safety
mechanism overlooking the attenuation
features triple parking has been
addressed and rear parking courts have
been avoid avoided at the same time
there has also been a series of ongoing
meetings with long Melford Parish
Council both before the submission and
then during the application process a
key part of these discussions has
focused on landscaping and open space in
order to achieve something that benefits
future residents whilst being respectful
of the existing Village the result is an
enhanced entrance of Station Road the
road alignment has been reconsidered
green spaces have been opened features
have been repositioned and the existing
spigot mortar base will be enhanced as
an entrance feature such an open
approach to Collective engagement has
helped to shape these proposals and has
also provided an opportunity for
discussion on certain details the result
is that there are no objections for many
of the statutory consultees and there is
also a willingness to support the
application by along Melford Parish
Council to my mind this is an exemplary
model of how to successfully conduct
positive and meaningful engagement which
Bloor and by the district council should
be incredibly pleased with
we're therefore looking at a reserve
matters application today for 150
dwellings with Associated public open
space landscaping and a sustainable
Urban drainage system it seeks to add
the required detail to the earlier
outline consent which is already
established that the principle of
development was acceptable on the site
since that time it has also become an
identified housing allocation in the
emerging joint local plan referenced
la113 therefore there is an expectation
that this site will deliver housing to
Long Melford which in turn will support
the growth of the district it's hoped
that the engagement carried out by blore
homes for this scheme goes some way to
integrating these proposals into the
settlement and are therefore
respectfully request that members
endorse their officer's recommendation
and approve the application today thank
you very much for your time thank you
are there any questions
this speaker
Council Busby it's going to be your turn
to the Busby thank you thanks
I suppose we yeah James hi
um
what are these squares all about then
if I can uh we've been engaging with
with officers over a lengthy period of
time uh and one of the things that they
asked us to create is these uh focal uh
the focal areas basically when we were
looking at where the road alignment uh
was located there were certain points
that people either walking outside of
the side tour actually through the site
would be drawn to and it's these areas
that have sort of attracted a a key area
of attention how can they be designed
what will they look like what will the
materials be how will people see and use
them on there and I think there's
there's three or so uh areas that uh
that Catherine had highlighted on on her
plan that sort of draw your attention to
those it was meant to be that when you
are going through the site you are you
you sort of go through various different
areas different experiences as you're
walking through them and the way to look
at those those particular squares that
you're talking about is a different uh
different type of material and I think
that featured in some of the the other
members Quest as well in terms of how
are they going to be a sort of shared
space
well sorry but they looked like they
were
a meeting place for cars
because they were the West three roads
came together
okay it was different Road surface but I
mean to me a square is where people sit
and talk
and meet
not where cars meet
[Music]
is that a question James
where do the people
pedestrians and the residents come into
this rather than the cars
I think that's a very good point uh and
one that has featured in our discussions
you have to remember that when we've
been having these uh these meetings all
the way through as the the scheme is
involved it hasn't just been us talking
to your planning officers it's also been
uh talking with the uh the County
Council in terms of drainage but also
highways
um how should I say politely we've been
cited and uh given examples of uh very
bad examples of which not to follow uh
and I think we probably all know where
some of those might be those are the
features that have come out of our
discussions of what we are seeking to
avoid and I think the fact that we are
looking at something that is car
pedestrian and cycle friendly has all of
those elements taken into account in
terms of the widths and the types of the
materials because I think we would
probably all agree that one of the the
areas that we as perhaps pedestrians get
confused with is how are those areas
perhaps delineated that are on there and
that is one of the key things that we
have been thinking about and focusing on
in terms of materials and how that would
work I think the key thing to remember
is that those identified spaces will be
seen differently it is not just meant to
be your normal stretch of road that
perhaps we've seen on previous estate
schemes on there
computer sorry but to me just to taking
out the point about the car is that it's
where three roads join but there is no
set of priorities to one way or the
other so it just seems to me that it's
there's an accident waiting to happen
there where people think they've got the
right of way and they haven't there's no
such thing as a right-of-way
thank you cancer beer you have a
question I can guess what it's about
thank you thank you Mr chairman yes I
will follow on from what I'm supposed to
be
okay yes I will take that off yeah
um first of all could you comment on
why the three roads that are dead ends
or Hammerheads whatever you want to call
them go right up to the boundary fence
why couldn't they have been stopped
short and a house put there sort of
blocked any future development onto that
field because from the looks of it it
does look like
perhaps not you but somebody in the
future is waiting to continue to go into
the rest of that field
which is what I think a lot of the local
residents were always afraid of
so just on that one and can you find
slide 15 while they're answering that
one please then I'll put my second
question
yeah with regard to the
um the sort of the roads that lead down
to the edges of the development
obviously we've got
um this followed the
illustrative outline master plan that
actually had a mind spine that led
through the development and those rows
that lead out are all feeding those
private drives and because they they end
up being cul-de-sacs that are taken down
closer to the fringes of development but
there is a landscape you know there's a
landscape buffer that runs around all of
that outer field edge of what I would
probably say is at least
10 meters in probably its smallest parts
to which will be
transferred over is actually open space
and there's walking routes without that
the only way that those roads have been
put down there are to just feed those
private drives and to give outward look
and development over the fields and in
every aspect that way so we've got to
put adoptable
roads down to those so we can actually
at least get um
fire tender and refuse Vehicles down to
those points to then feed those private
drives that feed off those
thank you we'll be in cynical I could
think they could be utilized going into
that field quite easily but anyway we'll
move on
um
that slide 15.
which is what I've got
um now those three squares is that the
area where
the chancellor Barrett mentioned about
shared space behaviors
in the road which is meant to discourage
cars from going fast and all this
business and my question is around the
edges of that would you be putting this
one or two meter grass Burge along with
surfaces underneath
but that's that the the three squares in
terminology and it's probably it's sort
of a form in actually saying they're a
square they're actually free the free
set to Noble points which then have
roads off them so as in class and
amazing a formal Square they're a nodal
point that then has a different surface
treatment that will be a raised table
um one to assist traffic calming but and
the surface material will be in Block
Paving as well as the footpaths and just
to create a different sense of character
what we will
um
in discussions
with officers through the application
process these were looking to just more
server purpose of one slowing cars down
at those points they do you get to a
point then you feed off towards the
smaller
shared surface cold sacks roads roads
that feed to the outer edges but those
nodal points as such are there with a
hard
to be harder landscape give you a
different character and slow you down
through that spine Road
I've just finished so you can assure me
that there is no grassed areas solid and
on to the carriageways that will be left
grassed and cars can effectively Park
two wheels on them no no that
that's roads and I know
um I know that I do know the difference
yet if I'm one of them develops yeah we
are going to are in tension with
alongside subaccounter council is to
block paid those service margins
good thank you
thank you
counselor
thank you very much
um
good morning
can you tell us tell us a bit more about
the early years this um a figure that's
quoted I don't know whether it's a
commutable sum or whether there is a
building on that site that is going to
be for that and I was a little bit
confused and
if it is on that site is there parking
associated with that for parents
okay I'll uh I'll make a start on that
one uh I think the the key thing to
remember is that uh from the the outline
application it was agreed that there
would be an area identified for uh early
years uh and subsequent to the uh the
Secretary of State's ruling uh there's
actually been a request already made I
Believe by the County Council
um it was an issue that uh uh was raised
at various points by the parish council
uh it might not be necessarily in in the
best location perhaps it could be added
on to the existing uh School area
unfortunately because that had already
been preset uh at the at the outline
stage and has subsequently been
requested I believe uh by the County
Council whether we believe in this room
that that is the right or wrong decision
that is the current situation that we
are looking at there will be a preschool
on that area on there there is an
identified uh uh area for that
I don't believe there's any parking at
the moment the reason being because
there is no design for for the preschool
on there uh so I would imagine how it
usually works is that there are a number
of spaces particularly for the teachers
uh on there and how that would work in
terms of where their entrance would be
and then where the sort of hard standing
play area as well but we don't have any
of those designs because that would come
through the the County Council but I
think the key point to make is in terms
of of monies or can that be moved around
it is something that that is fixed and
that the County Council are are Keen to
to see uh uh developed out
right so who will operate it
who would who will operate the early
years facility will it
will it be we were put out to a tender
to find someone to run it or
again uh unfortunately I've I have no
idea how the the County Council operates
in terms of their uh their education uh
uh elements on there who they would get
to run those things it may well be
through uh part of the academy system I
I don't know but this is obviously a
small site for uh for for early years uh
and it is one that they have been very
keen to see brought forward
um if I can uh chair and and counsel
about it might be one that could be
taken away because it obviously has come
to the uh to their attention and they
have made a request for for that site
okay
see today or is that just the the the
sum that we're approving
it's just the land available for the
early years
and then County will obviously build
that out and bring that one forwards so
it's just making sure within the site
that there is a parcel of land allocated
for it as per the agreement section 106
agreement and there's also the
contribution as well which has been set
out in the section 106 agreement
well it is the land as to how County
Council bring it forwards and and how
they deal with the parking facilities
will be down to County Council
so that will be a separate application
or
yeah it's not part of this that all of
this application needed to do was
provide a certain site for it and that's
what law had done
well
we you know we can only deal with this
one as you used to tell us a lot
uh
uh councilor Park request go on
the chair I think um right I think so
very kind um just a point of
clarification really if I can um because
I think um Catherine mentioned in a
report that the roads are going to be
adopted but the report actually says
that the management company will be
established so um I'm thinking in
respect of the squares that we're
talking about who's going to be
responsible for those coming back to the
point of the counselor
um uh Barrett mentioned earlier and
maintenance and things so who is
responsible is it is it is it the
Residence or or is it the the local
Authority
the the squares will form part of the
adoptable Road and so they will be
responsible and transferred under a
section 38 to South County Council
whereas refer to the management company
that is the basins and the the
um public open space
Council Junction
thank you thank you
um can you explain why brought the still
installing gas boilers when many
developers are now moving away to zero
carbon alternatives
yeah I mean as far because there's no
actual specific requirement to
as much as we know it's
um probably going to be coming it's not
as an uh policy or requirement that we
have to sort of comply with now
um we are
um
aware and understand that even though we
are
um certain stored gas boilers there are
um conversion sort of kits and stuff
being investigated to potentially use
hydrogen in the in the future and stuff
you know with other schemes that are
wider this will be built out before the
sort of actual requirement for you know
where it's
um a building regulation requirement to
um
not use gas anymore will this site will
be built out
should it be approved prior to that sort
of timeline and requirement for that you
know we're on other
cool more strategic larger sites we're
sort of constantly having
um regular meetings of energy suppliers
and stuff like that to work out how we
will deal with that requirement when it
comes in the future but at the minute we
don't and we've got a specific policy or
building regulation requirement
aren't you just passing the future cost
onto the residence rather than just
going a bit above and beyond there and
just taking that there it
there is the question of um
the boilers there you know boilers and
other things will be there suitable to
essentially be converted
and at the minute the those sort of
um
Technologies are probably ongoing and
being established but it's not like
anything that there is a
need and I guess you could say that
residents will look at that if they need
but there's not a Quant for them to
actually need to change it over in the
future it will be will be more a choice
because there'll be the element there's
a lot of people live in houses with gas
boilers and it'll be at a point where if
um
you more likely choose to do from an
existing housing stock then
um
what you're actually enforced to do now
casual McLaren
thank you
um
can I just clarify this
three locks of of six six maisonettes on
site is that right
be lots of two I think
can I ask what provision has been made
for the people in the maisonettes to dry
washing and things like that
you are
it will be a joint
Garden that they're each Mason net
obviously has one up ground floor one at
first law and there will be joint
immunity area that they can actually use
okay and
is it accessible yeah yeah
there'll be access to their immediate
it's not like sort of located away from
the actual building or entrance doors
themselves
thank you
thanks for hanging
if you're in by default thank you Mr
chairman I know you're trying to let
everybody else have a go as well so it's
certainly Fair
um
question really relating back to this uh
to the Future home standard and zero
carbon emissions Etc
um
everybody makes a big thing about
keeping houses warm
but we've heard quite a lot just
recently about high temperatures and the
inability of most modern properties to
be kept cool
what are you doing about that and
secondly based on the indications on
page
excuse me yep page at 100 of our of our
report on the
size of new owner occupied accommodation
required in baber over the next 18 years
but I don't know when that's starting
from
knowing our Figures it's probably about
1821 but um why are there over 50 of the
homes four bedroom when we know that
there is mention on some of these other
pages about older people also requiring
desire for Chalet Bungalows and a strong
demand for two-bedroom apartments and
three-bedroom houses why have we got so
many four bedroom houses
overall across that site we carry out
our own market research to what is
actually suitable for the site there is
and provided across the whole site there
there is a range of housing types that
range from one beds up to four beds
there is also as we have also found in
sort of the situation over the past
um
sort of 18 months or so for the with the
pandemic and what have you that sort of
people are operating from home as well
so as much as it's a four bed house we
have a range of four bed house sizes
some of that are at the very compact
more smaller end that those you know if
one of them about words you know that
that smaller fourth bedroom could then
just even be potentially used as a home
office or something else so long along
those lines so they're what I'm saying
we're not at the very large
um massive end of four bed sizes we have
we are even our most more I suppose
compact four beds you could just argue
that it is really a large free bed so on
on that side of things and the the range
of hashtags as I said we have got
um a mix range from one one to four
across there that and those percentages
have sort of been driven by a sort of
sales team and market research
um
and going on to sort of have a point
about
um
yes there is the the Energy Efficiency
in the and the highlighting carbon
reductions but we
um for our energy assessment and what
have you looked to do a
that 10 carbon reduction but there was
there's nothing
um involved or nothing specified or
nothing to look at into sort of cooling
of households or anything
okay so basically did you have one more
question
it's okay to say that you've got to have
some hot houses where you're going to
make some decent profit to cover the
cost of the 35 affordable housing I mean
we understand I think we understand that
it is an it is an issue personally I
prefer to see the right mix of houses
rather than too many affordable ones if
necessary just um the wall facing that
you showed the pictures pictures of
there were some zebra
looking wall faces not seriously
planning on doing that are you
yeah I think there's some some elements
that um when we were going through the
design process yeah there were some
elements of mock Tudor within long
Milford itself there are existing Tim
frame frame buildings that obviously
date back
um
centuries before before now but some of
that and that mock tube is only on a
handful of house types it's not sort of
like it's looking at everyone and it
just sort of adds variety of interest to
the street team
if if I can add to that chair because I
I don't know if we're sort of concluding
the comments on there but there's
there's a couple of things just to
mention uh I think the the design is a
very good case in point of where
different people's thoughts and opinions
come together uh we haven't come up with
those types of designs on our own uh it
was one that was uh in many instances
LED uh by by your officers who wanted to
see something introduced something
different on there where does that come
from where do we get that sort of uh
idea from and again uh if we all had our
discussion on here we may all come up
with with totally different ideas of
what might be acceptable I think the key
thing is that this site
is brought forward as best it can so
that it fits him with the rest of the
community so that in 10 or 30 or 40
years time people look back at that and
with at least an element of Pride that
it's trying to do its best by
integrating in there and that kind of
leads into exactly the same situation in
terms of housing mix because every
single time that an application is
brought there is always a concern raised
about the type of housing mix that's
being provided and that the best way to
do that is to have uh sensible
discussions using information which
which may well be perhaps not as
up-to-date as it could be and I I
totally take councilor hinton's point on
there uh there are other experts uh that
you your offices sort of input in terms
of local community needs as well but
equally the house builders your blowers
and other people from this world also
know the type of people that are are
requesting types of of housing in a
local area and it's trying to get the
best of all of those things on there
which I think
I would say wouldn't I we've tried to
get on there including an element of
Bungalows and the different types of
types of of sizes there so
each one of those that we probably never
going to necessarily agree on all of
those but he hasn't one that's just been
simply thought up by us it has been a a
series of conversations over a long
period of time
[Music]
that one
oh
design and style is a an individual
thing just to me I think are they
painted or are they going to be wooden
or bit with beams on there it just it
just looks strange
anyway it's probably me but I mean
when they got when they don't sell them
David you can have a look
that's about
um I just want to pick up further on
Council Jameson's point to you about the
gas boilers being installed in in brand
new houses when we know that those are
going to be phased out it seems very
strange to me
when you've got an alternative that is
available currently which is ground
Source heat pump which admittedly would
might not be suitable in some properties
um a traditional properties but it
probably would be suited to my brand new
house with good insulation
combined with solar panels is is it a a
financial uh
decision
or or I mean are you doing this
Elsewhere on your on your other sites or
where is your thinking going
I have to say sort of currently we
um
uh a sort of Team you know after
I would say it's sort of our head office
team that are looking at sort of how we
move our specification specifications
forward and how we're dealing with
energy supplies and whether it's
elements where one thing we're not
looking at is ground Source heat pumps
um we are investigating possibilities of
air source heat pumps but there's
there's also difficulties with
some of them and we obviously got the
button up
the fact of how you then he internally
they require larger radiators and other
stuff so it the fact is it realistically
where we are now is because the
requirement doesn't
um
enforce us to do that now
um we're
um
not that far down that road with those
those sort of Technologies and as that's
coming we're looking at that we're
building it into because we're trying to
find out you know all of it our energy
suppliers and stuff like that there's
more demand if it's air source heat
pumps and the the electric side rather
than actually getting gas to the site
and it's then whether that
infrastructure is actually there to
serve the site in the first place
so
a lot of our reasoning is sticking with
gas until sort of almost building rates
takes us to that point
anyone else
if not thank you very much gentlemen
thank you
moving on there are no other supporters
objectives but we do have one of the
ward members present John Dunn's
unfortunately having to deal with a hero
wife
but councilor malvasi you have five
minutes to address the council
as board member very much thank you
chair chair of long Melford Parish
Council representatives of long Melford
Parish Council met with Bloor who took
on board many of their comments four
times however they've not altered their
plans with regard to key issues which
were reproduced in the officer's report
these are CO2 emissions claiming now
that they're only going to achieve 14.5
percent less than is required as I said
at our first meeting this development is
an opportunity for blow homes to Lead
the Way by setting the standard in our
combined response to the challenge of
climate change
water
blue do not believe in gray water
recycling as being a necessity however
we need to be more ambitious gray water
recycling installation of heat pumps
will be compulsory very soon there's no
photovoltaic panels to generate
electricity and make people more
sustainable a development of this size
should be more forward-looking and
future proofing now the dead end roads
has re as has been raised previously
creates a fear in the village that it is
for future development towards the
bypass the shared pedestrian cycle at
two meters is too narrow the local
nature reserve as the Melford walk is
being considered as a shared
access with bike users and we've been
turned down at two meters
you've got to consider that this is a
housing estate with buggies and
wheelchair users so where are they going
to go housing styles are referred to
policy cs15 at para 7 of the nppf
proposals for development must respect
the local context and character all new
developments should be required to
demonstrate the principles of
sustainable development and in
particular where appropriate to the
scale and nature of the proposal should
one respect the landscape landscape
features streetscape townscape and so on
the parish council has not been shown
any evidence that this important
criteria has been considered or has
influenced layout and design although
it's been requested a major development
in a medieval village with three grade
one listed buildings renowned for its
Heritage streetscape and Landscape
should be should have a positive
contribution to these features instead
of proposing standard style properties
that will result in the development
being like any other housing estate
anywhere where in the UK and with some
of the buildings similar to buildings in
Cheshire black and white beams housing
mix of 50 proposed open market
properties a four-bedroom our survey
indicated that over 70 percent of all
residents over 16 said four bedroomed
houses were not much needed it was
Bungalows and two to three bedroom
houses which were much more in demand
blower home statement in the officer
offices report States the parish had
concerns we weren't providing enough
Bungalows there would be 14 Bungalows on
site with a variety of other houses and
sizes but that doesn't tie up with table
3.3 on page 10 of the design and access
statement which lists only six
single-story properties so gentlemen
which is it six or fourteen the
Strategic housing comments received an
officer's report says at 3.6 the open
market mix has been provided in detail
but the applicant is expected to have
due regard to table 4.4 C in terms of
the portion of one two three four
bedroom homes for open market sale
table 4C indicates that over the next 18
years baber only requires 21.5 percent
of four bedroom properties but needs
more two bed at 36.1 percent and three
bed at 30.2 percent surely BDC should
not agree to over 50 percent of four
bedroom houses various conditions agreed
outline are not wanted by The Village
without consideration of local needs the
county demanded space for second early
Years Learning space the local primary
school has the capacity and is willing
to expand to its provision two sites
seems Madness
most bus stops were also requested with
hog in service put parts these are not
welcomed they're not wanted the village
desperately needs a pedestrian Crossing
only having one to cover a three-mile
built up Road area para 12.2 of the
office's report refers to Parish Council
concerns in relation to a previously
agreed and completed section 106 while
their comments are noted it's considered
imprudent to alter the existing section
106 the people of long Melford disagree
with that statement it's crazy to insist
on things that locals don't want surveys
carried out by the parish council for
the neighborhood plan shows average
daily volumes on the b1064 of 6.4 000
Vehicles southbound and 6.5
000 Vehicles Northbound 50 going north
exceeding by 5 miles per hour 86 percent
of those traveling south doing the same
your time your time is time is up okay
thank you very much thank you everyone
any questions for the ward member
Pastor Parker
um thank you chair thank you to
councilman the obvious question is is
does longmelford Parish Council support
this application it would it would
appear at vehemently objects to this
application
sentence that I wasn't able to read out
says that the Parish Council on the
whole supports the proposal isn't true
for the reasons stated above and the
planning committee should not be misled
by that statement
thank you
well I suppose the next obvious question
is why does the report say that the meal
for Parish Council does support yeah
the comments provided within the report
were taken from their their first
initial correspondence with us which was
on on the whole largely supportive I do
believe that in the report there is a
sentence from a super Parish Council
which was part of their response and
there has been amended changes in
designs since then and Recon was sent
out the parish council hadn't at the
time of committee report and I don't
think they still have hadn't responded
to that so it may be that that their
stance has changed since then therefore
it's not captured in in the report
okay any more questions for the board
member
cancer is
thank you chair
um it's interesting what you said about
the um preschool
are there any places in the ordinary
primary school I mean how is the
um the role there that's my first
question
[Music]
all right thank you and the second
the second question was
um doctors surgeries the doctor's
surgery again
um that's outside control
and it's outside counties control
sorry thank you
thank you uh yes can I ask you had you
brought up with the applicants that one
or more of your Parish Council meetings
with them
um the question of Bungalows because
obviously from day one we always knew
that they were going to have to have an
element of four bedroom houses to help
pay for uh well to help pay for the
whole development with or without
affordable houses and what was your
understanding of that thank you
the issue was discussed at one of the
four meetings and the council was led to
believe that there would be 14 Bungalows
on site
40 Bungalows 14
14. how many have we got now six
apparently all right open market so is
there some affordable
um bungalows
yeah so in total there are 14 bungalows
in total so that's a mix of open market
and affordable
okay
thank you
thank you I was interested in your
figures at the end concerning traffic
flows in either direction would it um
surprise you to know that the current I
say current because it seems to change
regularly without consultation with
members or anything else
infrastructure delivery plan which is
part of the evidence base for our draft
local plan
makes no mention at all about any need
for Highway improvements in the long
Milford area
I hate to say this counselor Hinton but
could you please repeat your question
because I wasn't it wasn't terribly
clear sorry
um
if you speak into the microphones
having these computers in front of you
it tends to divert the noise I think
um
would it surprise you to know that the
current infrastructure delivery plan uh
I say current because it's changing
quite often and with no consultation
with members or anything else and
provides an Evidence base for the local
delivery plan the local planning policy
local plan uh makes no mention at all of
any highways improvements needed in the
long Melford area
um it wouldn't surprise me at all
um the fact is that we've got one of the
longest main roads going straight
through the village and there's only one
Crossing Point
only one pedestrian Crossing so people
in the nursing home on one side have to
be pushed up about half a mile to The
Pedestrian Crossing then they go across
they can do their shopping whatever it
is go to the Post Office and then they
have to repeat the exercise
whether they wish to go to the building
on the opposite side of the road they're
in wheelchairs to be safe they've got to
be wheeled up to The Pedestrian Crossing
cross then back down
um
yeah
thank you great answers uh with two
points coming out of the last question
The Pedestrian Crossing
um
you'd want it in this area nearest to
this development I assume and
um and it is a busy area I'll give you
that but obviously your local County
councilor can bring pressure to Bear if
there was a need for a pedestrian
Crossing in that particular area I don't
know if you pursued that or what your
views on that secondly I didn't see any
um report anything in the report saying
that uh the speed survey had been
carried out was this one done by the
parish council or is this an assumption
because we all know perception of speed
isn't necessary 30 miles an hour
okay
um this the um speed survey was
conducted by the parish council
um it was to do with the neighborhood
plan
um we do have SIDS in place which also
track
um speed and numbers so we've got that
as well to support the findings
um now then the county councilor is in
fact pursuing The Pedestrian
um
Crossing
um why at that point because it is
actually on a Bend
and it and then Road Narrows
um and it does cause everybody a lot of
concern because there are a lot of
houses on the other side of the road who
equally attend the primary school and
therefore would and it would be able to
enjoy a safe pedestrian Crossing to then
get to school
does that answer your question councilor
beer yes it does but you've got to get a
case that the the
um residents of this new estate would
need to
um have this pedestrian Crossing to help
them access the road as you say to the
school is a very good reason
um I don't know whether at the moment
I wasn't aware because I could have
perhaps asked the applicant as to
whether they'd consider putting in a
pedestrian trust there because that
might help but it's obviously have you
spoke to them about it we can still ask
them are we
let's go
yes then in response to
can I just finally answer councilor
Beer's question
the development
the side of the road where the
development is there is no footpath
until you get to Roman way whereas there
are footpaths on the other side
thank you yeah
yeah pretty easy you could respond to
I think that's something very very
interesting too for us to to take away
uh and perhaps Stephen might be able to
uh interject from Bloor but um I believe
from the previous uh outline scheme
there was a couple of uh of improvements
that were being looked at for some of
the bus stops and I believe that time
has moved on since then and this might
be something that could be Revisited uh
in place of
thank you obviously that there's
contributions there and those in bus
stop improvements there are
part of the current section 106
agreement but if that was it's whether
the southern County council could do
that I suppose without maybe varying the
106 or how they choose to actually sort
of spend their those Monies
there are also still contributions
coming forward
from this development so there's another
angle as well
just by Health in great cornard we had a
hundred home development and I was
saving up through County Council funds
to pay for a pedestrian Crossing which I
believe at the time was about 32 000.
this development came along and they
paid for it we've managed to get it
because the school children as you've
referred to so that's the sort of figure
you'd be talking of which I would have
thought to get Goodwill from the locals
it's well worth to consider it thank you
Mr chairman thank you thank you judgment
right if there's nothing else I'll throw
it open to debate
would anybody like to kick off
counselor Busby
yes well I guess
we're having to look at this
thanks to the Secretary of State
um so I take it it wasn't in the
neighborhood plan
um
look look to me long Milford is one of
our special towns
this is a development that's
at the approach to the town
it's on the opposite side of the road to
most of the development therefore
it's a new development on agricultural
land
and it's creating
an impact
there's a statement that's going to be
made by this development as you go into
long Melford
and therefore I think it has a
a bigger role to play than just build
houses
to me when I read through this and I
think the
uh Parish Council report was absolutely
excellent probably one of the best we've
had
and I'm glad that some of the items that
they picked up
were responded to but it just seems to
me that this is a development that's
just doing enough
and to me that's not enough for the
location that this should be the play
Space it's minimal the affordable
housing mix uh the affordable housing
and the mix of Market houses is okay but
it could be better Energy Efficiency
only just
what's required the cycle footpath two
meters not really big enough parking
spaces
probably only just enough garages that
are designed for for bikes not for cars
the preschool
it's it just seems as though we've
missing a big trip with this we could
have created something which was really
worthwhile and would be
something which and
the area could look on with pride and it
would maybe lead to an expansion of that
particular site maybe they don't want it
yet but at least if it looks great then
future development could come along
willingly at the moment it's going to be
forced so I'm just disappointed with it
it could have been so much better
and I think
the lesson we should have from the
Parish Council report is they should be
involved at the very earliest stage
let's face it the locals tend to know
what's best for their area the sooner
they get involved
the better the developments will be
end of preaching
thank you Council if I say Council
Parker
thank you Chet and I
Echo
sorry
I Echo a lot of the sentiments that
councilor Busby has has said there and
and what's really
um you know of course cause a real
conundrum for me is that um you know
when I was reading the report I thought
was this the best is this really the
best that we can do given all of the you
know all of the news and the length of
time that this has taken to come and the
fact that you know we refuse this as an
authority it went to appear went to the
Secretary of State Etc
um
is this the best that we can do because
Milford is a a special Village
um but then having said that reading the
report I was I was comforted by the fact
that the parish council were of the
opinion that they were broadly
supportive only to find out that it
transpires that they're not so that's
thrown a real curveball here now
um and and I I so whilst I agree with uh
with Council buzz me the the problem and
it's a huge problem that we've got here
is that what we've got to ask ourselves
as this committee is
is if if members are mind to support
this is that good enough is that the
best that we can do for the community
given that from a statutory point of
view from a planning point of view
our officers have identified that it is
so you know on what basis are we going
to are we going to disagree with their
offices but um could I just ask
um actually Catherine at what stage is
long melford's neighborhood plan at this
stage
every two seconds it's
um I think it I believe correct me if
I'm wrong it's still in the early stages
at the moment I just happen to have
checked counselors
yeah so um
oh sorry with your permission
um chair the
um neighborhood plan is
at its final write-up there's been a lot
of consultation with the planning
department here at Beaver
um and as I say it's at its final
write-up being submitted I was told
September
this year
thank you
could could we could we just yes sorry I
was just gonna I mean that's not
anything different to what I was going
to say on our website you can see the
progress It's Made I mean the original
designation was 2017. it's been ongoing
the last thing reported on the website
is that um there'd been uh habitat
regulations assessment Etc and the
screening the termination of habitats
and that was March April 2019 so um the
councils described what's happened since
but in terms of its weight it's still
pre-submission so it carries limited
weight
and just to say that they're in lies air
conundrum chairman because
um as as we all know and as we've said
many times before until it gets to that
examination between examination and
referendum there is very little weight
that we can we can we can attach to it
thank you
thank you Mr chairman because well I
fully support my two predecessors
comments on this
um it is very disappointing and I think
it's fair to say to the applicants it
wasn't
um supported by the local Long Alpha it
wasn't supported by the planning
committee they recommended refusal all
right and inspectors looked at it it is
over with all others and so we have to
accept that and we are where we are some
of us felt that long Melford has done
its fair share and this was a step too
far but can I just ask the officers
have you got the best deal out of them
because it doesn't look that way and I
just wonder whether we can
uh whether we we can have any more
discussion with them I know this is
reserved matters Mr chairman I respect
your comments on that
um but at the end of the day
we're most likely going to go down the
road eventually of approving this but
at this moment in time it's not all
there it's not got all the things that
we want and and I think that perhaps um
certainly The Pedestrian Crossing in
should be uh looked into and I'm
surprised perhaps that our officers
didn't pick this up I'm surprised that
the local County councilor didn't get
involved in this
um because
um you know there's something missing
and at the end of the day I feel a long
mouth is a special Village we all know
it
um and we all know
that when this if this site is developed
it won't end there
that Big Field well I know you know we
we know we know concentration
thank you chair um yeah totally agree
with the previous members who have
spoken as the applicant has said he said
numerous times they've done just enough
basically they've just got over the line
in terms of the energy efficiencies
they've done the 10 they were asked to
the company of the size of law you'd
expect would be able to go that bit
further and try to produce something
that is
stands out and makes it makes a
statement to other companies and this
you know I just don't think this is it
actually Hanson
well we're all sounding a bit like a
sort of me too me too aren't we we're
all saying basically the same things and
I agree with everything that's been said
up till now what I would just say is
that this committee last meeting
recommended on the approval of Reserve
matters on a development in my Village
and there was a zebra Crossing proposed
in that that was insisted upon by the
County Council highways so I think we've
got to ask ourselves are we questioning
the decisions that come from some of our
so-called statutory bodies enough are
they actually doing their job properly
because we are the ones who end up
picking up the problems
okay
thank you um
yeah it's interesting there are elements
here that are quite attractive and I I
like the entrance the look of the
entrance because I think it does build
on other areas in Long Alfred
that newer Estates like Roman way and
harefield that have a very attractive
um frontages onto the main main road and
it's probably because they were built
before we the developer had to provide
so much affordable housing and so there
was a spaciousness and a generosity of a
scale it's it's notable
but
um yes and and also the um early years
that might be very very useful for
parents living there but I am really
disappointed about the energy element I
think it's
it seems odd that a developer wants to
put in place gas into a housing estate
you know it's got to provide
all that infrastructure to provide gas
to each house
is so short-sighted
um and I know the alternatives are a
little bit early stage but no no I think
that I think
um
on balance I'm going to recommend that
we refuse this application
um and like to propose that
yeah
that is supposedly
do you have a second
all over the place cancer Johnson
thank you
now
sorry can't surprise me well yeah
I'm tempting
I think the problem is we're going to
struggle to find grounds to do it
um I I almost would suggest that we
offer defer it to defer it we should
spell out what the priorities that we
want from this development as should
long Melford and if it means that we
have to reduce the number of affordable
houses from 35 to 25 then we do it we've
got to expect that the developer wants
to make a profit it's only natural but
it's ridiculous
that's having achieving one element of
our planning requirements and screwing
up all the rest there's an opportunity
here and I don't think we've grasped
this I think the best we can do is to
defer it
for further discussion
um
and hopefully it'll come back and we'll
feel better about it I agree with you
um the proposal and second level would
you withdraw your motion
how do we go about this
uh thank you chair yes so I'm taking it
we're not a point now we're thinking
about refusing
um I take it the members want us to go
away and come back with something better
yeah
um I I do understand that the general
sentiment behind that but I'm not really
picking up what what you are expecting
um there's been a lot of discussion and
debate already with the applicant
between their men officers I know Paris
has been involved in conversations but I
know they don't buy into the scheme
that's here or not all of it anyway
um the the designs I don't think are
that bad to be honest with you I've seen
a lot worse so we're looking at a
couldn't it be better yes it could but
it probably more expensive so that's why
they're not doing it is it bad enough
reviews no I don't think it is what is
it actually that members want us to do
please I think the comment
perhaps the need to take on board is you
can't use I've seen words this is a site
a village which is meant to be the
epitome of what we are as a district
council in terms of it's it's a very
important Village and it's going to the
Busby here said it needs to be seen when
you come into the village as being
something that's that's right at the
moment if you're giving it marks out of
100 and it's getting 40 and it's only
just good enough as you can see worse at
30. we want something coming in at 100.
perhaps I'm being a bit ambitious but
this and I think that's what people are
saying that and also I I think the the
the the question of energy
I don't think you think it's been looked
at well enough and if you if you're
going to have a first-class facility
then everything needs to be first class
apparently
um I don't know whether your the agents
are picking that up but that's what I'm
picking up from everybody at the moment
that we ought to be doing something and
and we should if we can defer that and
get something better in place them
That's How we'll go
um I understood share yeah I mean it's
long enough to beautiful Village
um that the site is
at the edge of that lovely Village it's
not it doesn't hasn't got a designation
it's not a OMB it's not Conservation
Area it's next to the opposite a special
landscape area so it's all nice but it's
designation isn't there so it's more of
this information for that sort of you
know it is a village how many listed
buildings 200
but what I'm looking for is
clarification or if we take this away
and discuss with the developer what
would you like from us what are you
looking for need some specifics really
so you can have meaningful discussions
about uh certainly I think there ought
to be some discussion on whether uh The
Pedestrian Crossing
um also some discussion on I think some
um better treatment of the boundary
areas where you've got these uh
Hammerheads sort of thing
um and
um
the design of some of them is not very
good uh we we don't like that particular
one that was shown on the air but
um surely they they've got a bit of
imagination of what they can do and make
better
and also the energy side of it
um if if they can't go down the road of
um underground
Heaton then try solar panels things like
that because I think some the Sun get
roses over the back there if I remember
right it doesn't comes around so that
could be done in such a way that you
didn't see them all on the front of the
hoses you don't have to see them no well
that's true
um so those are just a further reasons
but I'm quite sure
the failing is this meeting is that
that's not good enough and I think the
the developer the agents are here that
they're sensible people that they know
that we're trying to find a way forward
and I think councilor Buzz we made one
important point that if this means we've
got to cut down on the affordable houses
by not a lot but two or three to help
pay for some of this then there's
perhaps room for negotiation yeah the
river negation
the affordable is obviously secured at
the outline stage so you'd be revisiting
the 106 in the outline so that that
would be a complication I I just need
some more about
the design is there anything that is
there that you oppose like a particular
roof pitch is there something you would
like more of it
but the Bungalows are showing at nearly
10 provision which
the sustainability credentials okay
there are some solar panels already but
you would like some more sustainable
like gray water I think you mentioned as
well
you raise your disappointment over the
design can I have your wish list I've
had Council of beers yeah well I think
um one of the things that we need to do
and it's not this is not just for the
developers I think we need to go back to
Suffolk County Council and talk about
this Preschool location site did we talk
about the design well
okay so it's it's just an individual
thing to me it looks false I don't think
we should be trying to create
uh an image of something which is three
or four hundred years old it'll make it
look false it's you can recognize when
something's false it's usually cheap and
nasty and I think that's what the
impression that gives is just a personal
view I think in terms of design I think
it's important that garages are big
enough to hold cars
if not you've got to provide another 150
car parking spaces if that's how many
houses there are
or however many or 75 if they've got 75
Gap with the garages
so to me it's
it's looking at the things that the
parish council said particularly
and go back to the County council with
preschool Energy Efficiency it's so
expensive to retrofit these houses and
hopefully they're going to be up for 100
years or more it seems crazy to design
them for the first 10 years and not for
the next 90.
doesn't he okay
so I mean they're the kind of things the
play Space if you could if we could get
rid of the uh the preschool space which
was
not really wanted by the parish council
and we could expand the playing area for
the kids that are on that side that
would be a good thing
so I think it's just a mixture of all
things yeah not one thing that you can
put your finger on and say no
I'm sorry I can't agree with that last
point about forgetting about the nursery
provision
I'm saying put it next to the school
where it should be where people want it
rather than put it in this site where
they don't want it we could use the
space better in this side thank you
the preschool provision was was Again
part of the outline so it seems like
we're going back a stage and revisiting
the 106 for the outline and I'm a little
bit uncomfortable about
doing that in the guys Reserve matters
application chair I think in what in
terms of visiting the the preschool it's
an existing thing it's been signed and
still delivered not delivered sorry but
um County have signed it you know it
have signed up to it it's a thing that
was agreed to appeal so um
charging
so
councilor engine you you please
the one thing that also needs to be
looked at is the housing mix okay
it's not compatible with what the area
of baber was it might be compatible with
what blog can sell but it's not
compatible with what baber wants or
needs
because we keep on mixing needs and
wander up so at the moment there's a
list of things there's the one you're
very uncomfortable with is the s106 a
preschool thing well putting that to one
side but that can be discussed at some
stage but at this moment nobody's
insisting that that's a reason but we're
talking about a deferment we're not
talking about a a
refusal we're talking about a deferment
this stage where I would expect most
things to be up for debate still
so yeah of course so we will
obviously obey your your wish and go
away and talk to the developers just
what the nature of the discussion would
be you want to talk to County about a
Crossing we can do that yeah are they
sure they don't want to cross it we can
do that
um there has been a feeling out there
for more sustainable credentials we have
some solar panels are you saying you
want more I mean that may affect the
design and you know uh gray water
recycling was mentioned as well the
broad point about design I'm still
struggling over we need a meaningful
beginning to that discussion if you wish
to change it
can I just come back on what the officer
just said there it's not that the county
have said they didn't want one
they haven't really or appeared to have
considered a pedestrian Crossing
I think I think I think that message is
coming through
but the opposite's concern is how you
sum up your feelings towards the design
better examples of house design across
Suffolk and across it's better
especially in within the village along
Melford I want to check could we just
see a few of the slides again just to
remind ourselves what they look like
sorry cat just to remind yourself
foreign
types that offend is something missing
that you think should be there
they're just not particularly inspiring
and chucking some black and white
stripes on them just seems to
you know it's like
like putting go faster stripes on a mark
one escort
is the form acceptable and is it those
points that offend you more can it be
left to a condition to agree the
materials or
thank you they all look the same if you
look at those houses and you take out
the white panels and you take out the
stripy bits
they are all exactly the same sometimes
there's two of them together they're all
a cable a Gable Den bit with a stuck out
of the the front they all look exactly
the same they've just as councilor Busby
said it's a bit like sticking stripes on
a Mark 1 escort they are all mark one
escorts they've just been painted
different colors or had different bits
stuck on them that's I think the the way
that you're going with that council is
that you would like to see more variety
of type of houses out there summation
foreign
for the size there was some concern
about number four bedrooms looking at 44
table 44c which I think um Catherine
helped shared with you did you share
that
um okay something to share with me um
it's it's not that far off I mean
there's there's a spread of two three
and four bedroom houses needed across
the district not one bed so much
um and it's it's sort of spread across
those three types so it doesn't stray
dramatically from the need but you're
intimating that a little bit less in the
four bedroom would be more to your
satisfaction
look I think the simple way setting is
look we would like to be putting this
forward aside
to win an award
to be shown as the best site in our area
at the moment we'd be embarrassed to do
that and that's the difference we
shouldn't be having to spell out exactly
how you design houses and stuff it's
feel like anything special which it
should be there's a golden opportunity
here to do something special with this
site and it needs to do that thank you
thank you councilor Parker
so I don't know why this isn't working
anyway
I mean the only thing I'd say is that I
I agree with all of that but what I
really want to hear from um from our
officers around this s106 because I
think we might actually be heading into
a cul-de-sac with this one excuse the
pun
um because well you know an s106 is a
legal agreement
um so it's all on a good saying that
it's desirable and we don't mind if we
lose some affordable housing I don't
think that's even an option for us I'd
like some some legal guidance on that as
much as I'd like to see it I don't think
it's an option
I was going to say the the um
can I ask one of my planner colleagues
does what's the description of
development that was permitted by the
secretary of state does that include
infrastructure elements including the
preschool I've got the appeal open I'll
just look it up please
[Music]
thank you Miss Jim I'll just make a
comment here
I'm all correct in assuming that blower
homes have a have a development the
other side of the house did on the way
to Braintree
yeah because if you look at that that is
an excellent disc that is that is a lot
different to that and it brings out the
different types of housing Etc so if you
showed something like that you'd
probably get the design sorted out
can I just ask her do you have a
there's a site near helset
Applause
that's right yeah yes that's excellent
as you're going on with breakfast on the
left hand side
so that's as a suggestion
okay
I know it is yeah okay thank you
please just one week
I think the story will find it yeah
um Mr chairman could I just come in the
particular site they're referring to at
Halsted
um actually some of us in this committee
set in on that at Braintree District
Council when that was approved
um and uh I remember it coming forward
because they didn't have their Five-Year
Plan that's how they got it in but that
is actually a wonderful site it enhances
the whole of that
um really look at that and then you'll
see what we're after that is excellent
okay
no you can't find it Well I can I'm just
trying to think what I'm actually
looking for I mean the description said
150 houses didn't say underscore or
anything like that so it doesn't mention
anything about uh
sorry partly what I was after but it's
still the point is still there's still
an important point to make that we we
have a section 106 agreement that says
amongst other things there will be a
preschool within this development so we
are we can't mess around with that
within Reserve matters unless we're
going back to the drawing board and
obviously that requires a cooperation of
a lot of people including the applicant
well can we work on the principle that
we can go back with most of these things
of what we discussed here the energy the
the design Etc
if there's a chance to look into the
s106 let's find out how how legally
bound we are with that particular one
but at this at this moment in time I
would think we need to to to to be for
it because all the comments that the
members have made and if that can be
looked at at the same time even if we
don't come to a conclusion at least it
could be looked at and with a
recommendation that you can't change it
well sure the section 106 is really
after funding for a for a preschool yeah
it doesn't necessarily matter where it
is providing the lands that can be made
available either on the site or
somewhere else
sorry God
I think we could be creating a different
Problem by pursuing uh that that line of
discussion about a nursery being located
by the school because there's probably
many of you know where the school is
located is right behind the main road
and the access to it is quite difficult
so if you're encouraging more parents to
go up to the school side aren't we then
creating another problem for long
Melford residents that they wouldn't
thank us for I think that the site would
be quite quite suitable for parents on
the the Housing Act where they live so
can we not tamper with that surely we
may not be able to
if we don't answer the question we're
forever going to be wanting to know
have you got it I think I think we're
sort of getting some shape to this now
so um you want officers to speak to
County about the possibility of a
Crossing
which I'm taking to be a pedestrian at
zebra Crossing yep
um you want us to ask the developer to
augment the sustainability credentials
which could be more solar panels it
could be gray water recycling
you would like a greater variety of
housing type and you'd like to look at
the number of four betters and try and
get that down
are these the Salient points could we um
in terms of the energy could we also
look at the actual heat Supply and heat
recovery
uses I'm sorry Council I can catch that
you mind speaking to your microphone oh
sorry could you also ask the applicant
to look at heat
um the energy Supply and heat recovery
options
in terms of sustainability
uh what we can ask I think policy wise I
think you're probably aware members that
position there still isn't it
because we can ask a question we can ask
this yeah
we also are asked because we do consider
I assume the garages are the largest
sizes that they build to they comply
with this um with the standards yeah
yeah
um but electric charging points I think
that's certainly something that is
coming forward so that isn't too
difficult that will go under the um yeah
thank you
okay
you have enough I think that that's you
know that there is some
specifics that we can work on chair
right so now we need to take a vote
can I have a proposal that we defer
Council must be segment with councilor
Hinton
thirded by councilor beer
okay thank you chair
thank you
are we open for a vote
yes your vote is now in progress member
you are voting for or against deferral
moment
I should just start that boat for you
now
you may need to log into mod Garth if
again
just waiting for one of those
thank you
chair that's 11 votes for deferrals
therefore
it will be deferred
thank you everyone for that one
I'll see you again for another day with
that
I have
I'm working for giving them a chance to
clean change
does people want a quick little break
okay
thank you
finally
okay thunder and lightning to follow
dc2101958 Sanctuary Fiddler's Lane East
bergold
so I just established John that you wish
to stay in the committee rather than act
as a ward member councilor Hinton yes
thank you
I will now invite Jamie to the case
officer
to give us these presentations thank you
thank you chair
so this application is for a householder
application
as chair alluded to a second ago this is
on Fiddler's Lane in East Burgos
let's make sure these controls working
there we go
so East Burger aerial map the site is
located just in this area here and we'll
zoom in a bit closer
the main roads on this side with
Fiddler's Lane that comes off
I'll just notice that we've got a number
of different branches that come off
Fiddler's Lane
this one is how you access the site all
these branches are also known as
Fiddler's Lane
and the access from here serves two
separate dwellings you've got this one
here and then the actual application
site which is this one here
which is set behind the row of houses
that face onto the main area of
Fiddler's Lane
so it just indicates the site red
outline plan
and then to give a bit more proximity in
terms of which house is which
so the application site is here
the second dwelling accessed off the
branch of Fiddler's Lane is here which
is known as rooftops within the report
you can also see house number 22
cartilage is outlined here it's got a
bit of a dog leg that wraps around the
back
of number 20.
and number 20 does a similar thing here
is cartilage wraps around the back
of these two houses at the front this
building here is an Annex
and obviously their cartilage is a
shared boundary with the site here
I think the other cartilage that I'd
like to point out here is number 15
which is also served off a branch of
Fiddler's Lane and is also Behind These
existing Road developments
and it's this house just here so that's
what we'll see in close proximity to the
application site as well
so just a constraints map we can just
see the settlement boundary of East
burger here indicated with the mouse
and also just indicated the two listed
buildings as you'll notice in the report
there's no harm identified to these
buildings as a result of it but it's
just merely to give you a context of the
sign
these are existing elevations
the existing house is an L-shaped
building
with an attached garage
you can just see the garage link here
which is technically a rear elevation
this is the elevation that is towards
number 15 which I just indicated on the
slide previous
it's existing floor plans on the ground
floor
this existing garage way which is linked
for a store
so just moving on to the proposed
elevations
you can just see the dotted line of what
is existing of the garage roof there and
Link
and the proposed extension is a first
floor extension above the garage and
Link area
and you can just see that on the rear
elevation as well which is shared with
number 15.
we have a number of openings at first
floor level and again that dotted line
here shows the extent of what the
existing garage is
so just the other elevations again
dotted line indicating the existing so
the proposed element
is this part here
and this is the other rear elevation
because of the L shape and you can just
see the proposal just protruding out of
that elevation there just for clarity
so these are the proposed ground floor
elevations uh ground floor has still a
utility room is what was the store area
we have a bedroom on the ground floor
and the I'm just trying to read those
the studio area and bathroom
and what's also indicated here is the
three parking spaces which required a
Suffolk parking guidance for the
dispatch building
and then on the first floor that first
floor area is one large space which is
being annotated as a library of course
could be used as an office of course
could be used as a separate bedroom as
well if needed you will notice though
that there's no first of all access
through the access to this element is
down the stairs if I go back to the
ground floor area and through the house
so the first slide here I've got is
regarding
um Street Scene impact you would see in
the report that there is no impact in
terms of the street scene particularly
if we look at Fiddler's Lane and the
gaps between the houses so just showing
their photographs through the individual
dwellings number 20 and number 22. you
can see that there's some trees in the
background there there's no planning
control on those trees so if they were
to be removed perhaps the development
would be seen from this area but it's
not going to have any impact it's still
set back it doesn't enclose any of these
gaps between buildings
so just looking at residential immunity
impacts which is one of the main
concerns within the report set out this
is number 15 that I showed you earlier
on in the slides I think what's really
key to point out first and foremost is
that they have a private rear amenity
area at the back and also a private I
mean patio area here
they have a front garden area which is
located here which is directly adjacent
to the proposal so there is going to be
an area of overlooking into this front
immunity area we also have a holiday let
that's on site within the cartilage
number 15 which obviously already has an
element of overlooking into this front
amenity area so it's considered not to
be significant enough to Warrant a
refusal in this instance
moving on to number 20. again with that
cartilage that wraps around the back and
is shared on the southern boundary
proposals just indicated in red line
here so that's the garage it will be
above there and they have an Annex here
the objection here is that this would be
overbearing on their plot
it's considered in this instance that
there'll be no overbearing measures to
the rear evasion of the main dwelling or
the majority of the Garden area is
considered there may be an element of
overbearing while standing in this
position here but this is very limited
area of the garden it's not again not
considered significant enough to Warrant
refusal and I can't quite make out on
the slides that I can see on the screen
the measurements let me just have a look
at my screen in front of me here
that line that I've indicated is 22
meters so from the shared boundary to
the rear elevation of the house the
closest rear elevation you're looking at
22 meters
yeah so North is facing this way so that
the proposal is more North is North all
Shadows would basically not be casted
within the site
within the neighbor's site
so I'm just looking at overlooking in
this instance this is existing
overlooking that I'm looking at here so
there is an existing window at the first
floor level on tank array and therefore
provides a level of overlooking already
that's existing and that is in a direct
line
the new overlooking would come from the
closest window on this elevation
given a 45 degree angle you're looking
at 20 meters to the boundary line that
has hedgerows and trees on it and then
30 meters
to the rear elevation of number 22.
it doesn't from officer's opinion is
that this doesn't increase any
overlooking that's existing already and
the distance between them would meet the
bre standards whilst it's not policy
gives a good indication of what's
considered acceptable
I will just flip back onto that one it's
also need to be noted obviously rooftops
which is directly opposite would again
have some level of overlooking to it but
this is 18 meters which is on that
threshold line of what's acceptable and
they're also existing Windows on this
elevation that already achieved that
level of overlooking so there's nothing
um
there's no level of increased
overlooking in that instance compared to
what's existing
so just some site photos you can see
that's an L shape this is the window
that I was saying looking into the rear
Gardens you'll just notice where the
angle of where this photo was taken by
this Arrow here so looking into the site
you can see the hipped roof garage with
the proposal that would come in at this
level here
just looking a bit further back
and this is my back is right up against
the boundary line where possible I've
got some bushes behind me here but this
is the boundary line of where the number
cartilage is so if you can imagine the
First full element coming into here the
window is going to be very much at a
similar angle to what this one is but
positioned here
so he's standing pretty much the garage
is here so first of all element will
come into this area you can just see the
annex of number 20 there in the
background and the rooftops of number
22 and number 20 are in here and you can
again see the hedgerows and trees that
are existing
they just note that the arrow is this is
where I'm standing within the site again
you can just see the top of the rooftop
of the annex there which is number 22.
and a bit further a bit closer so the
First wall extension is coming to this
area here
and if I just flick back it might also
be worth noting these boundary trees
that you can see here and the boundary
that's shared with number 15. they
indicated that has the holiday let in
the front immunity area that there will
be a level of overlooking into but these
trees offer some kind of shielding
so that is the last slide
have to take any questions share
thank you Jeremy have any questions for
the officer
councilman hinting
thank you Mr chairman but a couple of
points of clarification really 0.7.2 of
the report on page one two nine talks
about flood risk Zone one considered
very low risk of flooding
there are no known issues of surface
water or flooding within Fiddler's Lane
while it was obviously dry when you went
there because if it's when it's rained
through this Lane is like one Long Lake
uh highways have done absolutely nothing
about it and they accepted that there's
a drainage problem along there so there
is a flood flooding situation along
Fiddler's Lane so that's a point of
clarification there and also for the
fact that number 15 is a bungalow
so any big massing to the
east of it as it would be
um would be much more dominant than if
number 15 had been a house
thank you
so apologies yeah the the clarification
on that is is that the branches and
Fiddler's Lane the branches are also
called Fiddler's Lane so what I'm
alluding to there is not being any known
drainage issues on Fiddler's Lane is
that particular branch
the addition of built form is not going
to increase the level of surface area
because we're going to build on top of
existing surface area so there's not
going to be any increase in drain
surface water drainage as a result of
that therefore it's not going to have
any adverse impact on existing
situations at all
right let's go and that was not
obviously clear from the uh the wording
of the report so it needed clarification
thank you any further questions
just one quick one on parking standards
what is the parking standard from
Suffolk County Council for six bedrooms
three parking spaces off-road
so it's the same as it is for four yes
so the other two people don't drive
obviously
[Music]
thank you John
any more questions
handsome cancer Darren thank you um
hello Jamie
um are we allowed to know if there's any
particular circumstances with the
applicant their reason for wanting to do
this
um
yeah so in terms of a house extension
there's no obligation for them to give
us a justification of why they want to
do something in terms of an Annex
situation we do expect some kind of
indication of why in this instance the
applicants have given us detail to say
that they have elderly parents that will
be staying with them on on occasions but
they are anticipating for a future use
that they will be moving in with them we
have received objections to say that
they have been known to use the premises
as an Airbnb but the application does
not allow any type of change of use on
this so if there was an Airbnb use that
was taking place they would require a
change of use then this type of
application that they've submitted
wouldn't allow for that and obviously if
it does transpire that n Airbnb uses
taking place then our enforcement team
will obviously invite them to submit a
change of use application
okay
is there a percentage increase that
this is increasing by already is the
footprint just remaining the same
yeah so the footprint of the actual
house is remaining the same because
obviously building at the first floor
level on top of an existing ground floor
level
um I couldn't tell you exactly what the
percentage increases
um but what I would say is there's the
policy hs33 doesn't require any uh
restriction to a percentage size
difference it just requires that the
design is uh blend the actual word is
blending with with the host dwelling and
surrounding areas so in this instance
because they're keeping the same pitched
roof degree they're matching the
materials they're actually keeping the
Ridgeline subservient to the main
dwelling its officer's opinion that this
would blend with the existing house and
surrounding area
thank you Jamie Brian public speakers we
don't have a representative from the
parish or an objector or a supporter but
we do have the applicant Jenny Spencer
Smith you have three minutes to address
the committee
good afternoon chairman and members
we are making this application for an
extension over the garage for three
purposes
the fundamental reason is to provide
ground floor bedroom and bathroom
accommodation for an older member of the
family who has increasing Mobility
problems due to a crumbling spine he's
currently able to live independently but
can hardly walk as far as 50 meters the
prognosis is that this is likely to
worsen with increasing rapidity
that we want to be in a position to care
for him I must add that it is not our
intention to use this space for any kind
of rental or holiday accommodation
the remaining ground floor space is
intended to provide me with a Pottery
Studio to house my equipment including a
kiln throwing wheel and a sink with a
clay trap
in addition to extra storage space first
floor would provide a sizable area
suitable for my husband's considerable
research archive including ample working
space not only for writing and
photography
but also for collating all the material
necessary for any ongoing Book Project
he is the author of some 55 published
books and his significant archive is
currently inadequately housed within the
garage suffering the vagaries of heat in
the summer and cold in winter
we intend that the design and materials
of the extension would match and be in
keeping with those of the existing
property and that of the other house in
our close rooftops and we would enter
the hard standing to create a third
parking space in front of the garage
leaving room for a fourth car behind if
necessary the height of the intended
extension would only be two meters above
that of the current roof line
as the case of its officer's diagrams
show the immunity area of number 15
Fiddler's Lane to the West is some 30
meters away from the proposed extension
beyond our house
while the adjacent properties to the
South are all more than 20 meters away
the set foot Annex within the garden of
number 20 Faces our garden and not the
garage
and to the east the extension would face
directly onto the garage of rooftops
as our property is situated to the north
of Fiddler's Lane there would be no loss
of light to any of our new neighbors
while the first floor Windows would be
cited at right angles to these buildings
so they would not be overlooked any more
than they are at present from the main
house they are all enclosed by a two
meter high fence giving privacy to their
Gardens from our Upper Floor windows
I therefore request that your Grant
planning permission for our application
please thank you Mr chair thank you
any questions for the applicant
cancer beer thank you just the point of
clarification that I may I you said that
the building would be two meters higher
than the existing roof line but you
meant the roof line of the garage didn't
you I did yeah yep that's fine no
problems thank you
any other questions for the applicant
no thank you
okay
John Kenton councilor Hinton you're
staying on the committee would you like
to open the debate you don't have to
it's not compulsory
Mr Mr chairman all I would just say is
before before the other members get
involved in the debate is that they look
at the revised comments from this berkot
Parish Council uh referring to its
neighborhood plan which has full weight
and to
the whole question of overlooking
although the officer has produced some
very interesting
pointed diamonds or triangles sorry of
visibility space but uh I'm not sure
everybody looks from a one one window
only
so I'll leave it to the members
cancel the beer
well Mr chairman I've read the papers
I've heard the officers presentation
really Annex this sort of thing is very
popular at the moment and should be
encouraged I see nothing wrong with this
and I'm quite happy to move the
officer's recommendation of approval
thank you okay do we have a second
okay so as
teacher yes I would gladly second this
and it's so important that people are
unable to have the elderly record
um relatives with them rather than going
to a care home and I think it would be
lovely thank you
thank you
any comments or do you want to go
straight to a vote
we can search about that
thank you chair members your vote is now
in progress in the app
[Applause]
thank you members chair that's ten votes
four and one against that's carried
thank you
that's being carried
right the date of the next meeting is in
the diary of the 28th
lie but
planning officer has informed me earlier
on that there's very very even less than
there is today at the end to be to be
looked at
um not not totally happy because we've
spent
a lot of hours here today when perhaps
they could have been spread out over
there too but you and I will have to
have that discussion sometime tomorrow
so it may well be postponed we'll let
you know as soon as possible
David you know you're getting no food
you're not being fed I can't stand
responsibility for that
yeah